happy Star Wars day everybody and
welcome to fat man Beyond I'm Kevin
Smith I'm mark barnard and hey hey man
may the fourth be with you ladies and
gentlemen indeed welcome to the fourth
of may it's not really this this is nice
man who knew that a bunch of movies that
we watched his kids would one day become
a holiday an international holiday
everybody celebrates Star Wars day
that's why we're all off from work in
school because thanks George Lucas yeah
George Lucas gave us a gift okay so
tonight what we're gonna do is watch the
Empire Strikes Back together all of us
but but I'm more concerned with marks
reactions and we're gonna comment
throughout now mind you since we're
doing it online there may be gaps
you know while one waits for the other
to speak I would I would since since
there is delayed time mark anytime you
want to speak if I'm speaking go like
this so I'll know to wrap up and any
time if you're on a tear and I'm like oh
I want to jump in you I'll raise my hand
and then you'll know to wrap up that'll
be a decent visual cue because otherwise
it's like I want to say something one
two three I want to say something
so classrooms not be like let's not be
like those people that digitally erase
the earpods from late-night shows to
high-back people are actually wearing
earbuds during these trying times let's
embrace the fact that we're separated by
a sea and ocean of Technology but it's
also bringing us together ladies and
gentlemen we me and Mark are going to
watch the Disney Plus version of Empire
Strikes Back we chose that yes not as a
plug for Disney plus we're not here to
plug them if I'm here to plug anybody
it's that Kevin Smith club.com go right
now but Disney Plus we figure a lot of
people have
maybe not everyone has empire strikes
back in their home viewing library
although what would you be doing
watching a stream at the scum and
villainy Cantina just because everyone
seems to have Disney Plus we're watching
the Disney Plus version mark do you know
if the Disney Plus version is the
classic or the one with like digital
wampa in it my guess would be that it's
at the very least of special editions if
not if not the most recent version of
the George Lucas la-dee-da so I think
there's going to be some some screams as
luke plunges down a Bespin tube that
hadn't been there before yeah I only get
something longer shorter but I think
we're getting some digital whiz-bang all
right we're gonna get some augmented
version this is not you know for what do
they call it disclaimer this is not the
version that Mark and I saw in the
theater in our childhood but it's pretty
close oh so close enough man but boy oh
boy not only is this a great Star Wars
movie in fact the best store was moving
one of the best pop movies ever made
would you agree mark indeed yeah I mean
it's it is I mean well we'll get into it
a little bit later because we have like
two hours and 20 minutes to talk about
Empire Strikes Back
but this was a very instructive movie I
think for an entire generation of
moviegoers who saw this at an age in
which this was like maybe the most
mature movie they'd ever seen and I'm
definitely one of those people it was
like why wait a minute this is this is
deep inside excellent point man it's
true this was even though it was a movie
about fantasy and characters who you
would come to know from a previous film
an adventure and stuff like that it was
kind of for lack of a better description
adult like you know not adult with a
look at like if they're dealing with
adult themes like Star Wars everybody
wins and so you go home feeling good and
stuff Empire Strikes Back they're like
this is life kid it sucks
and people get frozen and taken away by
bounty hunters yeah this is a this is a
generations first tragedy
I'm pretty sure and as such it's super
important to me because you know after
this why does any movie need a happy
ending damn fire didn't have a happy
ending
it's so true alright kids lie on your
[ __ ] up we're about to dive into Star
Wars universe we're going to see some
Warren in the stars man we're at the
zero mark right now on Disney Plus are
you ready to press play mark barnard
I am indeed my swatches are synchronized
is that is that a watchman swatch that
you've got no I wish it was wouldn't be
great I got one for you if you want one
they sent me one when the TV show was
but I came home after the tour they sent
me this amazing watchman box that had a
mask in it because you know in the show
although I was using it here in the real
world that turned out to be handy you
came with a t-shirt and it came with a
watchman swatch bro so I had a circle
and you are a I know you could [ __ ]
call your buddy Damon Lindelof and be
like send me real props from the show
but I got a watch for you market alone
below I will market or Bob utilize
responsibility he reminds people
constantly that him and Damon Lindelof
or like this wearing my mask where'd you
get your mess broken eye but no not
unless you know Dimond love my friend
cuz I do you know the guy that made lost
who here knows who's got two thumbs and
knows the guy made lost
hello mr. Bernard all right here we go
starting at zero we're diving into the
Star Wars magic counting down in three
two one and we press play I've got mine
muted and I've got my subtitles on so
you won't hear is good I feel just yes
that's the way to do it we don't want to
pay Disney for this I've already
overpaid Disney for Star Wars throughout
in my life and believe me if my mom was
here she would back that sentiment right
away she'd be like half my life was
spent buying that stuff and then she got
mad when I opened
Jay and Silent Bob's secret stash and at
one point I was like well you know maybe
I maybe it's time to let the Millennium
Falcon go and so I sold my childhood
Millennium Falcon my childhood I kept my
figures my action figures but I let a
lot of vehicles sell you know at in
Jane's on Bob's secret stash in the
early days and stash nothing and my
mother cried from Sheila who's meant the
world she did I made my mother cry and
I'm not sure what it was because she was
like those meant the world to you when I
was a kid but I saved everything so it's
not like she's like you're not
sentimental enough I think she was like
I paid a lot of money for that [ __ ] you
just sold it anybody's will give me the
profit back I invested so much money in
Star Wars did you buy the toys when you
were a kid I was a huge toy collector as
a kid I was like the I'm gonna eat all
this general meal cereal because I know
there there are some friggin liked
ratings if I eat the cereal and I get
these dolls I'm sorry action figures not
dolls let's be clear yeah man what the
heck but I had Star Wars was the movie
that changed it from dolls to action
figures that's how they made it okay for
us to play with dolls as little boys
because they were like this isn't a
dolls an action figure emily has figures
full of action that was a term that was
born in our lifetime to convince us to
buy more toys but I'd argue that you
could have written Star Wars dolls all
over this and kids still would have
bought them by the droves because this
was our religion were you a big Star
Wars kid or did like I live with Star
Wars but Empire was my true religion
Star Wars I mean a new hope is the first
movie I remember seeing like literally I
can remember that experience of being in
a theater watching that movie seeing
that the words come up just like we saw
in the beginning of empire with the
words the scroll coming over and then
like the blockade runner and then the
friggin starter story chasing it down
like all those things are vivid memories
for me and so every every other
experience of movies is comparing to
Star Wars especially the experience in
the theater and so to the point where
it's seeing the special editions in the
theater again even seeing you know the
prequel trilogy even seeing this new
sort
the end of the skywalker saga every
single time i see the 20th Century Fox
logo I expect Star Wars to follow you
know lucky just oh it's a different
movie now oh alright because after this
I usually see the Lucasfilm all shiny
shiny and then but but and then when you
don't get that but I'm just like
disappointed by whatever is fine like
these movies prove beyond a shadow of a
doubt that that branding works because
still we're waiting for Star Wars to
begin after every Fox fanfare this I
remember this is a movie that captures
my major imagination right away as a kid
because of the probe droid coming out of
the you know the this is the second one
that Luke's watching now but the first
one before we got to see the Probot rise
yeah and instantly I mean it's probably
because of John Williams iconic amazing
score but instantly you knew that was
bad [ __ ] it looked like a Death Star
robot looked like a Darth Vader robot
right away the world building began you
got to remember when we were kids we
didn't have a [ __ ] ton of sequels we had
movies and a franchise for example they
made a lot of James Bond movies but they
rarely talked about the previous
adventure bond was never like well in
dr. know this is what happened like
there was no mythology or something jaws
2 did reference the events of course of
Jaws Bad News Bears and breaking
training acknowledges that Bad News
Bears happened before but generally
speaking there weren't mythology sequels
this was one that was just like remember
all your characters they're all back and
this is what they did the next day more
or less so you know you were like huh so
once you see Han or Luke once you see
really Luke on the on the tauntaun and
whatnot you know you're back you're like
there's our old friends
now we're which one of these like Star
Wars whenever you visit a planet George
Lucas was very fond of thee oh no this
planet only has one ecosystem this is
the snow planet or the sand planet or
the swamp planet or the gas again there
is there a beach on Hoth somewhere
on the other side of the planet were
there like I know there's some [ __ ]
going on in the Northern Hemisphere but
down in the south of Hoth always [ __ ]
man it's [ __ ] it's like Miami
if the vacation spot which which of
those which of those temperate zones was
was your favor you a half guy like when
you see an offer you're like oh I'm all
about this [ __ ] half here I'm not you
can quote me on this not a hot take but
[ __ ] Dagobah man I'm saying like swampy
and shitty with monsters that will eat
your droid and whatnot give me hop any
day of the week I know how to stay away
from mwamba and plus the hop seek Hoth
planet gave us one of the greatest
sequences in all Star Wars history the
snow walkers the a dads look how [ __ ]
shitty he is to the general the general
like talking Colin ignores exactly what
he says like general I gotta the [ __ ]
out of your knee will hate to lose a
good fighter but [ __ ] will be happy to
lose a rude prick like yourself
thanks for not even hearing what I said
this is adorable look at how adorable
Carrie Fisher looks man she's an
baby-faced on at this point there's our
princess and you know this is her with a
different hairstyle than we'd seen
throughout all the Star Wars and that
higher style became iconic so once this
movie begins you're like where the laia
buns and they never bring the Leia buns
back in the hole never coming back I
mean there's there's a lot and we Ward
mantle they referenced Ord Mantell
there's some world building too because
remember Ord Mantell was in the comic
books the Marvel comic books as well
there were other references to Ord
Mantell outside of Empire I
I forgot how quickly we pick up with
them with Han and Leia kind of already
having been in a relationship I think
because it's already gone from like when
we laughed less when we last left them
in a new hope it's just a man you're not
all about the money anyway I knew you'd
be back and then here's a friggin medal
and now it's as if they're like in the
middle of a breakup in a way or they egg
had been together and then broke up and
now it's it's just been weird for them
hanging out and how sexual sexual
tension right before the consummation of
a relationship I would guess it as you
know in a world where he's
like you know I you know I just she's
like I just as soon kiss a Wookiee and
he's like I can arrange that you know
that's that snappy banter from the front
page or something like that you know
these two are falling in love and [ __ ]
but I tell you man I there's a world
where somewhere they made a movie called
Stark cook a solo story you know it's
all about how he arranges bug and you
know meet and greets with with Chewie
that turned very sexual and it's the
tagline if had a tagline for it it was
it would be he watches wookies make
whoopee topped out that take it look at
that get been delayed off this do they
have much of a relationship han and
c-3po in Star Wars I think there's just
a little bit on the Death Star
like they're they're not hanging out a
lot like they're on the Falcon a little
bit they're on the Death Star a little
bit but I think they have maybe eight
lines of dialogue eight couplets between
the two of them and now it had like The
Odd Couple if I c-3po I'm like you know
man like get off my goldenrod dick I'm
trying to help here like we what we all
fought the Empire together and blew up a
[ __ ] death star you can give me [ __ ]
on Hoth like [ __ ] you I was there I
helped that kind of [ __ ] yeah maybe
three POS a little bit maybe there are
two is like r2 was like I helped I was
in the friggin x-wing where were you
three p.m. c-3po is like I was there to
support Princess Leia when she was
looking at the big round screen and [ __ ]
like that he's like I was there to tell
her the gods and [ __ ] you I helped he's
in for a penny in for a pound or two
he's like you're such a [ __ ] show up
those two that's the bickering that
comes from an electric relationship
that's been going on for years when did
you first hear that the the story and I
don't know how true it is I don't know
how apocryphal it is but the idea that
the this entire sort of Wampus sequence
this whole bit where like Luke he gets
hit in the face and his face is all
[ __ ] up and scarred because it was to
excuse the fact the Mark Hamill looked
so different between a new hope
and empire because he got in a car
accident very bad car accident yeah he's
got I heard that even then as a kid like
because it was in the news we didn't
have like you know the Internet of
course but like People magazine existed
so like they talked about him being in
an accident and but the face like how
they worked it into the movie was more
like me putting it together rather than
like reading an article cuz as a fan I
knew he had gotten hurt and so in this
movie when he got hurt it was like ah so
later on when he looks card you're like
how it all it kind of tracks could you
imagine if you bought a pizza and that
pizza cut your [ __ ] arm off he's like
oh my god I got my [ __ ] meal I'm
gonna have a good ass time tonight eat
the [ __ ] out of this and wholesome his
meal came to life cut his [ __ ] arm
off man and it's a Star Wars movie so of
course some are more some hand was cut
off he never goes for legs man like you
know yeah I would have went for the
wampa leg cuz you cut those [ __ ] legs
off he's like ah then you got a shot of
him on the ground like [ __ ] boxing
kalenna man he's just that's horrifying
but they weren't going for har anything
I love Hans fatigues in this movie like
this is my favorite Han Solo outfit [ __ ]
the one from the first moment the best
and she hit the classic one the Han jato
Teague's with the jacket I would wear
that coat today if I could find I've met
people in the real world
I guess they sold it on some like Disney
shorts tour or something they must make
that Han Solo Hoth coat because I've
seen it on like a [ __ ] fan cuz I
would love to put on that coat and be
like then I'll see you at out like every
time I leave the [ __ ] place
we had the shittiest thing to do to a
dude who is like you should be careful
out there mr. solo you might dies I can
I'll see you in hell and then the other
guys just like what does that mean why
would I see ya like [ __ ] why am I
going to hell I'm a believer I've never
heard you talk about Jesus huh you know
what I'm never talking him again and
then he pairs up with c-3po and they
talk about shitty han is immense
soon the cancel Han
Hansol it's like dude never mind the
horrifying notion of what happened to
Mark Hamill in real life this movie
introduces two things number one the
tauntauns sound like the Hamburglar
they're always like Rob so I say George
Lucas owes Disney a buck or two but they
also are gonna introduce us to how to
save a life by taking another life so
you know that that's something or using
a dead life I guess they didn't really
yeah Han doesn't kill Han doesn't kill
that tauntaun he's just like I got a
date odds in here but let's be honest
Rick and Morty style you knew he would
have he would have been like Luke's more
important rabble and that thing goes
down and then he cuts it open and [ __ ]
but Han got lucky and as much as port
Anton gets exposed to the elephant's
this is one of greatest scenes in movie
history right here man we're gonna I've
never been inside that you know it
chills up the spine every time right
because like the sound of the door is
like slowly winding up and the music is
crescendoing and then chewy looks over
and sees it and then I remember in high
school any time you know we had a
gymnasium like everybody else and any
time they went half gym and they closed
the giant door I would always go every
time I see a giant door closed in life I
movie studio sets they got big giant
doors my seam close on this is the
beginning of ghosts in the movies right
like you know her worst ghost Ben's
voice in Star Wars when he's like use
the Force Luke but this is the first
time he [ __ ] sees Ben Kenobi and [ __ ]
yeah this is a very coincidental Vision
Quest where it's like you happens to
fall down here and then you know obi-wan
it's like do you have to go to Dagobah
go find Yoda and then as soon as obi-wan
disappears then Han Solo comes like
walking in sec OH
it'll happen right here how did that all
have
because Harrison Ford was like I'm not
doing all that exposition I just wanna
ride up on at on time let the old man
ghost to the exposition he can talk
about me talking all that [ __ ] I'm here
to rescue I'm rugged I'm a carpenter man
this is the this I was so happy to see
these two come back together right
because they're their new friends in
Star Wars oh there it goes BAM little
bit of motion there blended with a real
tauntaun hepl not real they don't exist
but a life-sized count on head I I don't
understand why in a world of fanservice
you know they echoed and brought back a
lot of things in the in the sequels in
the the new trilogy that they just made
but nobody did tontons I always thought
that like Ryan's movie the last Jedi it
shouldn't have been new animals that
they were riding with those creepy human
faces they he should have done tontons
man that would have been dope psycho
[ __ ] that's where they got them that's
where the Tom John's went and [ __ ] but
you know like I don't want to do old I
want to do new which I totally respect
but I was love when JJ did rise this guy
Rises Skywalker like you've got these
people on this on this planet and
they're riding some kind of horses and
then they get those horses on the actual
like super crazy Star Destroyer thing
it's like I want to see Finn right in
the tauntaun in dead [ __ ] kid man
once again you've improved a [ __ ]
movie like yes why not
an army of [ __ ] tauntaun that would
have made you feel more remember in the
trailer when people were like [ __ ]
space horses what's this all about
imagine if it had been a fleet of
Townsend's running across the deck of
the Star Destroyer you'd be like that's
how I would that's what the image I
would jerk off to in the city this is
the first time we see the snowspeeders I
mean engine Bach I mean there's a lot of
different mean but now fake they came
later snowspeeders first introduction of
a cool new vehicle in the Star Wars
universe we were used to the x-wing
we're used to the TIE fighter we're used
to the Millennium Falcon Star Destroyers
but this is where you know the Probot
that done count doesn't just look like a
asteroid [ __ ] but this is like ooh
like I wonder if they're gonna sell that
damn Skippy they sold that and then they
introduced on the same planet the atom
as well the other new addition to the
Star Wars Armada which like as a kid you
elect they look like metal elephants and
they were based on the movement of
elephants if I remember correctly can we
talk for a little bit about the fact
that we're like 15 minutes into this
movie and and we haven't seen the empire
that is going to be striking back like
it is literally just like sure we saw
the pro the probe droid and that we
start on a Star Destroyer but we haven't
seen our main bad guy of course is
waiting right and it's like our heroes
are not in any way contending really
with the Empire it's just oh it's cold
out there
Oh Luke got lost don't know we got to go
save Luke you know we're gonna slice
open his tauntaun ago we found him and
he's in the hospital and it's like oh
where's the threat per se that we were
told was coming you know these movies
really think about the infinity war
speed they literally open with like Loki
getting killed and for getting his ass
beat by the big bad guy no they don't
bury the lead they like here he is this
place you know these cats are more
leisurely and sure they're like we'll
get to we'll get to evil metal man just
learn we won't catch up with old friends
we want to set the world build it takes
his time this is a late 70s they start
making the movie early 80s of course
when it comes out as a more leisurely
paced think about it people look
everybody who makes a movie an action
movie a pop movie a Marvel movie looks
to this movie as the example that
everyone wants to set it's the high bar
tomorrow it's a hit
but nobody goes at the glacial pace of
this [ __ ] like you're absolutely
right it's crazy I mean but remember
this kill you kill thanos before the
opening credits literally it's like you
chop his head off and there's bum bump
up up look wait what we got the credits
you guys it's crazy man infinity war an
end game go a lot [ __ ] faster but yet
both of them of course would probably
give a nod to this movie as like and
look at how well they're balancing
multiple characters at once and
introducing
sexual tension now those two kissed in
Star Wars she like yeah they're gonna
keep kissing but all the sudden Han in
the beginning is getting all sweet honor
and [ __ ] and that's when you realize
later in life that George Lucas made the
mental calculation and had to be like I
have to show that she's interested in
this guy because I'll get two bites of
the Apple one they're gonna think it's a
love triangle and then I'm gonna creep
them all out for generations send them
to therapy when everyone finds out
they're [ __ ] twins and they don't
find that out till the third movie so uh
uh George Lucas probably ruined our
emotional psychological childhoods more
than Steven Spielberg who kept me out of
the ocean my entire [ __ ] life these
filmmakers were not being responsible
with children whatsoever
not at all I'm like I I think back when
I when I watch the scene again I'm like
listen George Lucas had the opportunity
to go back into all three of these
movies and change a bunch of [ __ ] some
[ __ ] that didn't need changing some [ __ ]
did maybe whatever you want to put John
without and I get it but all kinds of
digital trickery to make it you know
kind of spiffier and spoofing and
whatever he could have changed that like
there's a world in which you could have
gotten rid of incest from this trilogy
George is like no that's gotta stay this
brothers had totally kids I mean we can
fix it I know Ben Syfy's in space that
it's different brothers and sisters in
space or whatever look at Chewie with
snow and more of that like that's great
look for the fueling hop always captured
my imagination I used to get like the
styrofoam or the foam that like came
things were packed in in a box and I
could cut this one and make it look like
their set you know what I'm saying like
with the jagged rocks
all right let's here we are here we go
how many minutes into the movie almost
20 minutes dude before you meet Darth
Vader again re-meet Darth Vader and this
is a different Darth Vader than the last
one we met who was like I have you now
why you know dude blasted out him from
above and then once spinning off into
space
this is the hunter this is the Darth
Vader who we'll see later on in road one
and he's single minded aboard his ship
the executioner men looking and his
helmet is shiny this time around not
last time and unlike last time he has a
purpose he has a mission and he wants to
find Skywalker he didn't give a flying
[ __ ] about Skywalker last time this time
he wants him did you even sense that as
a kid because as a kid I was like how
does he even know who Luke Skywalker is
and of course we find out and stuff but
he hits the ground running and that's
the difference between George I think
wrote the screenplay to Star Wars and
what's-his-name Lawrence Kasdan and
Leigh Brackett those cats were like
alright let's let's but they are they
laid track that we still run our trains
on today you know in terms of three acts
storytelling structure in a giant sci-fi
fantasy movie yeah like and it's the the
what as we come out of the New Hope and
we come into Empire and the first time
you see Vader like you get it he's
pissed off the Luke Skywalker blew up
his big fight and shiny [ __ ] like it's
revenge you see did you see how close he
came to beers Darth Vader he's like
sorry and you can't you got to apologize
even though it's his fault you gotta be
like sorry even though he was the one
that got uncomfortably close to jihad
your peripherals wearing that [ __ ]
helmet you know what I'm saying like I
don't wear a helmet I wear this hat and
sometimes I don't know who's next to me
wearing that [ __ ] helmet how do you
know the proximity you are two people to
one be man medical droid this guy I
think didn't he pop back up and not him
but like another one yeah I GE or RG 11
was like I'm a nurse droid which I
thought was beautiful in Mandalorian but
he's look at that that's sweet but I
thought that to me also pops up in Rises
Skywalker when carried sort of like
passes out and then there's one of those
medical joys tending to her as she is in
her forced coma or whatever don't do you
really think like you'd be this casual
[ __ ] who literally saved your
life by cutting open a dead tauntaun
taking you inside and then you just like
ëifí like what like go down there man
give me a [ __ ] you know give me a
good talk
into [ __ ] like you mean the world to
me I wish you weren't leaving talk it
out and [ __ ] my it's not really possible
that Han Han never told Luke that he put
him inside the [ __ ] tauntaun like
Luke passes that's true wakes up in a
medical day like some day I may be one
be the medical droid told them later on
he was like your friend stuck you up at
Anton's
ass ooh the meditation chamber one of my
favorite introductions and Empire
Strikes Back him alone in that dark evil
egg where later when when when sits
close he takes his hat off man
that's [ __ ] I want one of those in
life I would have take my hat off in my
office when I'm alone and [ __ ] I want me
an egg that closes like teeth so I'm
like nobody could see me I take it off
that's his jerk-off pod we all know that
isn't that's now we didn't know that as
kids we can't see the lotion in the
corner we can't see the bunch of tissues
over there it's all digitized and then
look he pulls up pornhub and stuff and
this category is men in uniform facing
away from us and he likes someone he
loves those pornos where people choke
each other out and obviously that's his
thing cuz it's happening right now this
is the first time like we saw him in
Star Wars do this [ __ ] to a dude in the
room remember when he choked the one
dude but look at him he's Chokin people
over [ __ ] TV could you imagine if he
was part of the Nielsen Denis Nielsen
family token show distance choking left
and right and stuff like that look at
this
it ain't Star Wars unless there's a
bunch of people surrounding other people
talking about war man and give it up for
this movie look at how in charge she is
you know Princess Leia of course showed
lots of moxie and take charge and she
was an action heroine in Star Wars but
here they show her as literally the
commander and all these boys are sitting
around and listening to her and taking
their orders from her and that was an
important thing to see I think when we
were kids because it hadn't been like
that prior they they didn't really like
do that in other movies you know not
even in like cartoon it's like you know
I I don't know it just made an impact
this is a gorgeous set man like look at
them taking great use
of the production value of just nature
with all that snow and then you put some
tech in the snow and this is the scene
man is like so chock-a-block full of raw
tension you don't know what's coming we
all know it's coming because we've seen
this movie a zillion times but the way
they build the scene out even though you
saw on the trailer
the snow Walker's coming I remember who
the ion cannon I remember I had the
rebel troop transport as a kid one of
the most boring ships they ever made but
even though you knew those snow walkers
were coming the scene that Irvin
Kershner the director of Empire Strikes
Back has constructed has tension running
throughout it you know like the juror of
Steven Spielberg would later show a
glass in a car of water rippling to
indicate that the dinosaurs were coming
in this movie it's the ground itself
here we meet dak who says he's ready to
take on the whole empire himself and
they're gonna kill the [ __ ] out of him
yeah you can take out the whole empire
[ __ ] you you can't make it past the
first snow Walker down CAD my [ __ ]
boasts tea and [ __ ] he's like I can do
it all Luke and Luke's like I wish I had
a better gunner man you're all talk dak
yes - leaving behind [ __ ] oops there
they are can I say the battlefield
tactics of the Empire or wonky as [ __ ]
because it's like I we're gonna land a
bunch of tanks and we're gonna march
them in a straight line towards the
rebels in a fixed position where they
have their guns pointing the direction
you're marching like there's no liking
maneuvers there's no like airborne
attacks there's no I guess the
Revolutionary [ __ ] war words we're
gonna stand up over here and you're
gonna stand up over here and just shoot
at each other for a while it's something
that that Ryan corrected and last Jedi
remember like fuggin they dropped those
ships and the at-ats roar the gorilla
walkers right in front of the front
[ __ ] door of the base it's not like
you know we're gonna [ __ ] march a
bunch time it's right there these cats
are waste based out they should have
just [ __ ] firing all the weapons take
one of them at-ats drop it from the sky
- it lands on the [ __ ] generator
you know okay I get I get that like
you're making this movie for children
and so you want it to seem as simple as
possible the bad guys are here the good
guys are here they're coming they're
trying to fight and it's all gonna go
down here but it's dumb as [ __ ] if
you're like a battlefield commander who
this the the the at-at Walker the a duck
commander and the a dat stormtroopers
the ones that and the snow troopers when
they introduce different designs for
characters you're familiar with I loved
the snow troopers they only get a few
seconds man but like they had little
capes didn't really serve a purpose or
anything this is a blue screen days mark
right like all there's much all blue
screen they don't do that no more now
it's all green screen it's all green
screen these days back in those days
blue screen there you go use motion dak
had just [ __ ] stash they got the whole
empire myself and he's [ __ ] dead yes
yeah thanks doc now yeah the miniature
work is just so good like they
completely sell everything and you know
that's just dudes who are like it's very
slowly there's no siege honest with you
you're [ __ ] for the first time ever
you're you're making me think
differently I thought it was I don't
think it was miniature work I was like
then must have built those [ __ ]
things right built a giant kog'maw once
they had to fill giant snow walkers but
you're right it's all miniature work
isn't it it's awesome you're in like
Dennis Muren
that's right you know hiding like in the
in like the Muppet half platform where
the a dad so like you know three feet
tall or whatever but they're still
moving every leg steady rogue - rogue -
of course is Luke right and that you
know rogue one is a movie a whole movie
look they're doing that thing from from
Captain America Civil War you know that
old movie like aliens man this movie
just [ __ ] works you could show this
movie to people that didn't see Star
Wars that's something that the Marvel
movies took from Empire strike
back like you don't need to see Star
Wars to enjoy the [ __ ] out of Empire
Strikes Back just like you didn't need
to see Captain America the Winter
Soldier to enjoy the [ __ ] out of Captain
America Civil War would you agree yeah I
mean it gets it gets deeper you know if
you've seen the thing that comes before
then all of these relationships all have
more texture to it same with the Marvel
movies like you're not you're not quite
as lost unless I remember my mom only
saw a black panther and so then she
wanted to see Avengers infinity war and
was like what the hell is this who were
these people like well yeah mom it's
hard to flip to like chapter 14 of a
book and be like what's happening now
but but yeah this is a movie that
teaches you how to watch it as you go
why do you think they designed those
x-wings where you need a [ __ ] r2 unit
a mech the metro is a tech droid or
Mexico astromech droid astromech thank
you you know there's the [ __ ] I mean
it's not the future it's a long time ago
in a galaxy far far away but look at all
the tech that guy look they could make
mini walkers little Adsit oh yeah at a
snow walker met up the snow trooper I
would do a whole [ __ ] series about
the snow trooper man like the
Mandalorian he's got cool affa too like
the general veers would eventually get
promoted from Imperial schmuck to Nazi
spy in Indiana Jones in the Last Crusade
that's right that's the guy isn't it man
it's it's I guess George Lucas made Star
Wars because he grew up you know in a
post-war era right following World War
two and then with the end through
Vietnam as well so unlike us we didn't
have a bunch of Wars growing up this
guy's like whole world was like are
always fighting somewhere and we lose
Americans boys over to some war overseas
and stuff it's kind of an anti-war movie
in many ways so you know in some ways of
course it's an action-adventure movie in
every way but it is kind of anti-war and
that could only come from a guy who grew
up through a couple Wars like it would
never occur to me to make
I didn't see any Wars that's why I
occurred to me to make clerks I worked
in a convenience but also think that
like to your point about why there are
like astromech droids because I think
George Lucas grew up watching lots of
war movies and there's always you've got
your pilot and you got your gunner
there's always like two guys in those
ships one Kentucky the other one of them
will probably die in the middle of the
mission or get shot and get out
fascinated like dak and so all of these
ships always have like at least two
people in them so that they can talk in
and amongst themselves as well as having
other people overhear them on the big
[ __ ] radio board of the Rebel
Alliance but yet his entire you know
mindset was always the serials that he
grew up with hit the flash Gordon's in
the Buck Rogers and the old war movies
like the entire trench sequence in Star
Wars is all like Old World War two
bomber footage that's what he cut
together as the temp track but like I
wanted to look like this bunch of old
bombers and fighters and stuff the these
battle shots I forget they're they look
expensive I mean they probably spent a
pretty penny this not so much idea and
also watch this [ __ ] this is the first
time you see somebody to use a
lightsaber in a way that you dream as a
kid like you know they're always they
used them to fight and [ __ ] like that
but like holy [ __ ] he just literally cut
that [ __ ] open with a light saber like
more of that less like a noble knight
saber - yeah I don't use to open doors
[ __ ] cans like just everyday I'm
seeing Luke takes out one or two that
one he took out the other one he talked
about like his core is his cord the one
that goes around my wedge did wedge
judge so so somebody else takes that one
down and Luke takes one down [ __ ]
overachiever this dude changing course
man I've always loved that one where he
[ __ ] back left and he's like it took
him so long to get to the [ __ ] power
generator and [ __ ] they could again just
drop a [ __ ] snow Walker on that [ __ ]
it's all so maybe you should bring bond
this next time if you get just lunch
especially because they have them and
you know what was that one movie last
last skywalk no yeah last was it no last
Jetta they had the bombs in space
remember with gravity yeah things drop
in space this he's very handsy with her
man he's always dragging her around and
stuff but she's so tiny
han had every intention of leave it all
here it come every intention of leaving
that Droid behind c-3po here it is oh I
love this shot as a kid I loved it man
when they bring in the Bam Bam Bam metal
man man man he's looking around where is
the boy oh look at this
they don't give a [ __ ] about c-3po and
he can speak every language like that's
the guy I'm grabbing man [ __ ] them [ __ ]
the astromech droid who can't I can't
understand beep beep beep this guy
speaks English I'm like let's take them
with us plus you can hide behind him
he's a human [ __ ] shield
you can't like Oh Aries again look at
the Falcon looks by itself in that
hangar bay everyone's gone they're like
we took all the good ships and left the
piece of [ __ ] behind so it's the last
one [ __ ] left in the parking space
it's like a [ __ ] gremlin parked in a
[ __ ] parking lot in the last parking
space at the back of the parking lot
meanwhile ya hit that [ __ ] man exactly
George Lucas stealing from Gary Marshall
man look at this [ __ ] this is so badass
they set up the [ __ ] gun and [ __ ]
their Lord and masters right behind him
meanwhile they're getting taken the [ __ ]
out and Princess Leia dude is like mere
MIT what is that a hundred yards from
the [ __ ] who like kidnapped her
and stuck needles into her and [ __ ] like
that that would be like her escaping
from Hitler and then like being in this
guy's car and she's like go go go go
it's [ __ ] hit go go and there he is
and he's like I almost had all of those
[ __ ] I want to see the scene what
happens next where Vader's like let's go
through all their [ __ ] and take the
money
they're all gone never
the see what kind of movies these
[ __ ] that this base is ours part a
but they're all clones right so I guess
they don't care so much well I mean are
they close though because I mean Finn
wasn't clones look kiss the
stormtroopers at this point are they are
they like the first order no these
stormtroopers are the end of the clones
I think the after the clone after Star
Wars they referenced that's when they
started just stealing kids or something
like that so each one of these guys is
from like New Zealand inside there
all right there are ladies right thank
you I guess 36 they share all look like
they're from New Zealand I mean as a kid
are you [ __ ] sitting there gone like
hello Loen shorter than the other any
space representation up there for me
hello these white suits anyway by the
time you see the movie do you know that
Lando Calrissian is going to be in it
like had you seen him in the trailer and
stuff um I don't think so and I've been
like have any real it wouldn't matter
honestly because I was here for Luke and
Leia and Han Solo and Chewie like you
know there's a new guy that I don't know
anything about okay sure I guess and I
think it Lando Billy Dee Williams means
way more to my mom than to me at like 10
years old it was like what's that my
dreams is in this maybe I'll go inside
Green V now my mom would have also
[ __ ] Billy Dee Williams and was very
happy to see him to show up in these
movies because she had to sit there I'm
she was like oh I like him he was in
mahogany
because she's a big Diana Ross fan so I
stuck to my mom into like in fact like
going to see I saw Star Wars re-release
before Empire came out because they
added a trailer for Empire Strikes Back
the first trailer and this was in the
days where you can't [ __ ] convince
your parents to see anything twice
because it cost money and [ __ ] now does
it please we I know we saw two years ago
but we have to go back and see it a Star
Wars again because there's going to be a
coming attraction for Empire Strikes
Back
I remember saying to my mom mom the guy
from mahogany and Lady Sings the Blues
he's probably going to be a Billy Dee
Williams Segal right Don will go so we
went and saw the movie see Star Wars
again just so we could see like a minute
and a half trailer which I've since seen
online and stuff always takes me right
back into that moment we leave Hoth
behind
we never go back now our adventurers are
often [ __ ] the galaxy Luke is on his
way to Dagobah these cats was firing the
ship like you know being chased by Star
Destroyers and I mean and Tie Fighters
and both Chewie and Han are like in the
innards of the [ __ ] ship like well
whose autopilot can't be doing a face of
maneuvers in [ __ ] like who was flying
this [ __ ] seem to respond by dreaming
remind you most of the sci-fi kids were
used to at this point was like Star Trek
you know 2001 a Space Odyssey all heady
[ __ ] nothing heady going on here man
[ __ ] like [ __ ] doc like yeah that's
kind of perfect for these movies no what
do you mean they couldn't do before you
couldn't do space battles like this
before you couldn't have the camera
moving this way before like all these
things are innovations of Lucas and ILM
and Dennis Muren isn't an John Dykstra
like how do we how do we make it feel
like get to a world war 2 war movie with
planes streaking and you know enemy
fighters and all that stuff and it was
impossible with the technology until now
and it was like [ __ ] it push it like
let's do all the things we always wanted
to do if I was the production designer I
would have been like Ken the Millennium
Falcon have no windows we save our sins
save our asses and stuff I've always
wondered about this I know like you know
the whole empires [ __ ] chasing him
and he loses some of these TIE fighters
like here bang but like you know he just
dips into a [ __ ] hole here where the
Empire go like you know like but dude
though do they later on start dropping
bombs on the planet or something they do
yes they do so they just bought
themselves
a little bit of time how long do you
think they are down there like an hour
parking job or something like that and
when do they enter the monster I guess
in this cutaway because we don't see the
mentor something's mouth and they don't
notice either where are they in the
belly of something or aren't is it they
were in at the things hole and it was
coming out of the hole to chase them I
think they're in the things belly as
soon as they fly in I think that's how
you're supposed to feel about that right
or are they on top of the thing like cuz
they're like something's wrong here and
[ __ ] like you know and then they take
off because that would mean the Minox
the things that are inside like are in
that thing's belly maybe I don't know
maybe I always thought they were inside
this giant space slug but maybe they're
on top of the space lug and then the
space slug is just chasing it out of its
hole when they leave on it we can figure
that out in a minute meantime yeah my
man here just had a whole conversation
with his [ __ ] gunner as Mark pointed
out that's smart you guys thought about
that
that's [ __ ] that's his tail man in
the world war two movies and [ __ ] so
like the timeline is wonky here though
because okay so han and and and company
are in the [ __ ] belly of that beast
and the Minox are all on that [ __ ] and
that feels like it's 45 minutes all
right it feels like maybe that's all
longer there maybe an hour meanwhile
Luke is unbaggable for what's got to be
like a month right cuz he's [ __ ]
training like he had he's gotta meet
Yoda he's gonna talk Yoda into doing
[ __ ] you're just gonna put him through
classes he's got to get the extension
degree from UCLA Extension whatever he's
got a watch Yoda milk the [ __ ] thing
of green milk and then drink it right
out of its teats and [ __ ] as where Luke
learns to do that yeah essentially he's
got a he does have to convince him and
stuff but I mean I wouldn't put it in a
month I always thought it felt like a
week and even that seems like a pretty
long time in this timeline really when
you think about it if you judge the
stories timeline based on Han and Leia
it's probably like four days that seem
right maybe cuz like cuz han and Leia
have to get out of the [ __ ] belly of
that beast you know finally get the the
hyperdrive fix to make their way to best
bin you know then do all the [ __ ]
land of [ __ ] but even that only feels
like they're there for like
day on bespin right like they'll and
he's fixing the ship they change clothes
they have a dinner dinner goes bad and
and meanwhile Luke has learned how to
kind of be a Jedi
yeah and people are always like people
attacked Rey going oh she's a Mary Sue
or whatever [ __ ] it's like this guy's
got like three days of training and the
names like I'm off to save my friends
the one that's not even he's I haven't
done with basic man I remember being a
kid and being like oh I'd be amazing
space shark space shark but I guess
we'll be getting space sharks and
[ __ ] Thor right love and thunder I
heard r2d2 with a pop-up telescope was a
new addition to the Droid where you were
like that's cool
but you know as we saw in the prequels
this [ __ ] could fly how come
he's not flying out of this place you
know what I'm saying yeah unclear this
said is awesome no I mean because Reagan
is all in interior set I think it was it
was supposed to be Pinewood but then
Pinewood part of it burned down so they
moved to Elstree Studios and they built
all of this indoors like every single
bit of it I saw a picture of a giant
overhead of place on the internet like
you know one of those flashback photos
throwback photos and it was massive like
you know to hide the fact that it was a
set they made a deep about all these
trees and of course they built all the
little sets mini sets within but there's
it's it's pretty damn impressive to look
at and one of those things really like
they would never spend that kind of
money anymore they would just like stand
over there from that green screen we'll
take care of you seen the Mandalorian
we're just doing that now we're not
building anything at a fiver again if if
I ever got my action figures as dirty as
he got his r2d2 my mother would have
stopped buying me I wasn't allowed to
take him out of the house when he well
he got his off-year to go look at that
size does matter mark ooh
superstar just a moment where we're
gonna see my man's like testicle like
head or something like that it was like
it was such a tease fleshy brain again
let's look show me show me man him in a
minimum and a minimum [ __ ] barely a
suggestion now was that changed to is
this one of those updated movies where
that was chained
to look more like Anakin Skywalker would
just was that the shot from 1980 and I
think that's the 1980 shot cuz I don't
think there's anything that would tell
that that's you know not Hayden
Christensen's head right like I think
that's and it's so tiny like you just
get a sliver of flesh and then it's the
helmets back on and vacuum-seal and then
you're moving through it but yeah no I
think it's totally it was I'll be honest
like you know it's it's I think it's on
pretty well on record that I'm not
[ __ ] bright when I was a kid I
thought Darth Vader was a robot I
thought all the stormtroopers were robot
so that scene when he's like [ __ ] you
know helmets off that was my first
inclination of like he's a human being
under that he's a guy in a [ __ ]
sue-ann didn't communicate that idea to
me as well as they could have been Star
Wars robot I I will admit to agreeing
and sharing that perspective when I was
when I was young because yeah like look
at him there's lights and shiny and all
that stuff they're all robots where
they're not robots this guy this guy is
like you know a Joe Biden level of
constantly is close to people he's
around I don't mean that politically in
a bad way or something is based on
pictures and stuff like that I'm all
into Biden but yeah he's always although
a lot of his hands were whereas I guess
antiseptic as you can be when Princess
Leia tumbles into you like he's not he's
look grabbing he's just like hey hey oh
and to be fair he also catches c-3po in
the hangar bay and Hoth before as
they're all leaving at one point he gets
thrown back and Han catches him and he
doesn't grope or anything like that
yeah ah just like you know like he's an
action hero let him catch everybody as
they stumble around the movies about a
bunch of [ __ ] stumblebums that can't
stay straight up on their feet Han Solo
is always there to catch him man vertigo
catcher I'm sorry you're gonna be I'm
here for you and Luke had time to like
build a campsite and everything
he's wearing his best Ben fatigues he
got drawer undressed because remember he
[ __ ] he got in his x-wing he was
wearing his x-wing half and [ __ ]
here he is wearing these bespin whoo
what we caught the action figure was
called best man fatigues should have
been called Dagobah fatigues because
that's seriously [ __ ] wearing but the
action figure said best men fatigue but
he do you think he got dressed or
undressed in front of our to d2 right
there mustards and put on a new outfit
do you think that confused r2d2 in any
way like hey man don't look at me or two
I mean or unless you want to look at me
or two or do you think are two shot
footage and [ __ ] the introduction ladies
and gentlemen of one of the greatest
movie characters ever created bar none
Yoda he has no known like you can't say
Yoda the space self he doesn't have here
he has no Jen I mean gender he's a guy
right he's gotta be a guy I mean um
that's unclear lady Yoda sound like that
yeah it's true I mean yeah I'll Linda
hunt of of aliens where it's like kind
of androgynous could go either way it
could be an argument could be made that
that Yoda is fairly androgynous he's
wearing Yoda Yoda was are what like kids
just think about you're already in love
with these Star Wars movies like I had
kids here's somebody your size and he
talks funny and and he's the size of a
muppet Muppets were huge then any and
he's he's a Jedi Master even though he's
little he's more powerful in this Lloyd
and his best Ben fatigues like of course
Yoda appealed to us as kids man and
patch them into life
Oh fight look at that he's got the
[ __ ] he's thick with 2 C's dumbs like
a chance off off a bro for like not
saving or redeeming Yoda but you know
Yoda had kind of lost his whimsy and
magic over the years and then various
incarnations and CG and stuff like that
they bring back Yoda the like come on
remember how much you loved Yoda when
you were a kid when he first came out
find that love
and with baby Yoda you know and then
they gave a tiny version of Yoda and
we're like that's the way to a [ __ ]
that's the way to bring your back
and now the whole worlds in love with
baby Yoda but you don't get there unless
George Lucas and Jim Henson and Frank Oz
make the trip first I mean to Jim Henson
single-handedly sculpt Yoda um I'm not
sure how much Jim Henson actually did
have to do with this I don't know if
this was like ILM Creature Shop I don't
know if it was all Frank Oz or if like
you know Ralph McQuarrie designs were
like no you should kind of be like this
and with the little ears and whatever
like I'm not sure I would love to yeah
dear listeners on the stream if you have
any information about whether or not Jim
Henson even showed up on set at all yeah
let us know cuz that's uh that's a fine
question mr. Smith I have an answer look
at that wide shot man you know that's a
real person probably a smaller person a
little person walking around Billy Barty
outfit yeah something like that or who
are of course what's-his-name the guys
would plays wicket later on Warwick
Davis Warwick Davis of course maybe
that's some early Warwick work although
work was a kid when he was in Return of
the Jedi right like all the enemies so
this I use Twitter out vast the the
Falcon is they show off a lot more of
the Millennium Falcon than you saw in
Star Wars and when I went to visit the
set of force awakens they said they told
me I'm sure they told the press later on
they built their Millennium Falcon's
they built one to scale interior and
exterior they built theirs based on the
blueprints from from both Star Wars and
Empire Strikes Back because they were
like they were kind of different none
they looked at very much the same but
the layout and what they built for the
second one like rooms like this that
didn't exist in Star Wars after all that
Hansy back and forth and and David and
Maddie from moonlighting type sexual
attention ladies and gentlemen this is
this this instigates my interest in
girls this is it this is you know scrum
yeah not so much girls because I always
loved girls but like romance like ah you
know off the
couldn't be more romantic when I was 9
10 years old like like this he's a he's
a bad dude man but he's a good dude
because like that he was gonna leave her
he was gonna go and be like I'm taking
off I got to pay off the bounty on my
head and then they she was gonna lose
her [ __ ] star war man and suddenly
[ __ ] this guy pops back in he's like
I got your back you know let's blow this
thing get the [ __ ] out of here like he
instilled [ __ ] hoping her she was a
hard case we all know that from Star
Wars and she believed in people and all
sudden this guy coming back more so than
Luke being a hero this guy coming back
captures her heart that's why she
[ __ ] kisses him man
not because he's like devilishly
handsome and [ __ ] like that
because he's a [ __ ] hero and then
[ __ ] block over here shows that room the
greatest moment in this movie man like
and she [ __ ] steals away to into the
ship but she's you know she knows better
she's number one she's boiled to number
two she's governor you know in the
government and [ __ ] like that
she shouldn't like this guy but like he
is literally the definition of a hero he
came back when he didn't have to and
then in the very in this movie alone in
the beginning he's taken the [ __ ] off
and [ __ ] and she's still trying to you
know hold down the fort
the last one off the ship and [ __ ] and
he has to drag her into his ship to save
her life once again she's like this guy
like I know I shouldn't like him but
[ __ ] he always got my back and like I'm
sure on some level she's like he only
wants to [ __ ] me but it goes deeper than
that
he joins her whole [ __ ] cause man is
one of the great love stories in movies
and it wasn't as explored as it could
have been but thank God it's there at
all cuz it created a sense of romance in
me yeah for sure and like in the same
way that George Lucas was was obsessed
with things that he saw as a kid that
romance is screwball romance from the
jump like it is all right his girl
Friday and the Thin Man and all of those
great you know Myrna Loy and Dick Powell
kind of things from the 30s and the 40s
and then Lawrence Kasdan was like yeah
all right sure I can write this dialogue
I can make him that you know dashing ro
who shouldn't be with her and she
shouldn't be with him but you know
circumstances it's it would later be
Romancing the Stone you know which is a
robert zemeckis movie but that was the
other sort of like here's this woman who
is kind of pristine and nice and here's
this dude who's kind of dirty and
circumstances forced them together and
they find love in in in ridiculous
places and yeah it is all that [ __ ] is
all in all thirty forty screwball comedy
stuff and I loved it to death kids when
we first saw this movie
Ian McDermott wasn't in it particularly
to this degree
this scene did exist with Darth Vader
kneeling on that platform so [ __ ]
metal man where he's just like my lord
and [ __ ] but uh they wish that I
inferred you could barely see the face
of the Emperor before I agreed you
didn't know who was maybe even creepier
and [ __ ] and he looks he didn't look
like this they didn't have as much
makeup but that scene is like you know
when he's like the son of Skywalker
nobody refers to him as your kid he
never goes your boy your child he just
keeps calling him the son of Skywalker
and then he's like how could this be
true let me go search your feelings
that's the first tenth if you're paying
close attention like that there must be
some sort of connection because why
would he tell a Rando to search his
feelings about some other Rando who may
or may not be known of saying like
clearly totally his search your feelings
is his way of saying you know bro that's
[ __ ] that's Padme Skid you ain't a
bad man you but we don't call you you
know more because you know and it's the
first time I think that we see somebody
like bigger higher up on the evil totem
pole than Vader like that's our first
real Grand Moff Grand Moff Tarkin and
Star Wars was technically his boss and
he answered to him and Vader appeared
his muscle to Grand Moff Tarkin and Star
Wars but this is like where you meet his
[ __ ] boss there's no reference I
don't think to an emperor in Star Wars
at all I think no but I mean you always
got the feeling that like Vader was
never afraid of Tarkin
do you remember if there was any
reference whatsoever to an emperor in
Star Wars I don't think there was I
don't think there was I think it's just
like Moff Tarkin seems to like I'm the
captain of this ship and Vader you know
was like I'm kind of the big heavy here
even though I'll kind of do what you say
and then ignore you when you know it
goes and you know [ __ ] hits the fan I'm
gonna get in my fight or I'm gonna die
I'm gonna deal with this myself but yeah
I don't think there's ever a sense that
that Vader is working at the behest of
somebody more powerful than he is yeah
Vader you could make the argument in
Star Wars is like odd-job with more
lines he's technically there to be the
Grand Moff Tarkin muscle because Grand
Moff Tarkin shuts him down means they're
gonna have a de and makes them stop and
[ __ ] but this is the first time you meet
Vader's actual boss but yeah it's true
this movie introduces the Emperor for
the first time the notion and in this
weird video hologram that we saw but the
one that's in this movie isn't an
incredibly good hologram yeah and it's
the first time that like not only is
there an emperor somebody above Vader
but it's somebody Vader's afraid of you
know and you never got the feeling that
Vader was afraid of Tarkin so yeah I
mean I guess you outrank me a little bit
but I'm gonna do what I [ __ ] want to
do you know I'm gonna never saw I'm
going we never we never saw him bend the
knee to Grand Moff Tarkin he [ __ ]
better this guy he bends it strong and
fit and fierce but he still bends it
nonetheless this is you know the seen in
Yoda house Yodas house is fun for a kid
because you imagine like oh I wish I had
this in my backyard I'd be video de but
this one moment in the scene is where
all sudden Yoda starts talking to
somebody else and Luke realizes that
he's not being taken to Yoda he is Yoda
all this time he's been like this little
[ __ ] green [ __ ] just take me to Yoda
he's a great warrior and a Jedi Master
and stuff and this is where you know he
realizes oh [ __ ] like this is the guy I
actually came to see yeah I'm here
you're right like the fact the Empire is
clearing the asteroid field and now
they're just dropping by
from tie bombers to try to shake out the
Millennium Falcon they know they're in
there actually it's no longer like we're
looking for him yeah that's beautiful
shot her alone in the cockpit and [ __ ]
though every curse directed the [ __ ] out
of this movie really did it's a
beautiful movie what else sir I know he
did never say never again later on the
James Bond movie but what had he done
prior to this I'm not entirely sure I
mean it's so crazy who to my doubts
alright so let's analyze the scene are
they end of things belly or are they in
the things lair I feel like all that
smoke on the ground is that they're on
that thing's belly I just want to point
out that that's the least futuristic or
space looking set of goggles like that
would never stand and any other Star
Wars movie they would gak it up and make
it their brand and ship that's literally
just a pair of welding goggles from you
know maybe Sears at the time or
something like that there's the there's
that famous door man I walked on well
not that one but on the Millennium
Falcon from force awakens and [ __ ] when
I walked up that ramp
I really miss but I thought if I was
like oh my god just like when they
[ __ ] ran from the Minox I might wait
my one great sort of like I guess
quarantine regret is that before this
all went down I never made it to the
galaxy's edge at Disneyworld I've never
been I've never done the ride I've never
done the rise of the resistance like
none of that [ __ ] me neither
that's what we do when we when when it's
all when we get to come back man that's
a reason to go to Disney when I tell you
what as an action figure collector you
know they had you know you could cut out
your UPC symbols or your proof of
purchase if you will rather and send in
a few and they sent a Minox mask kit
where you could get the masks that you
put over oh that's so cool figures man
it was pretty dope that's not an in 95
match though is it
that [ __ ] well actually this yes
predicted the corn
t-man in fact I want my quarantine mask
to look like their mask and [ __ ] they
pulled out my NOC masks I think in force
awakens alright so he just fired at the
ground I my whole life thought they were
in something's belly but it could be
that they're on top of the [ __ ] thing
I don't think so because when they fly
when they get him the Falcon and they go
out there flying them through that
thing's teeth as they escape so I think
I think I think there's I think it's a
confused thesis he's trying to have his
cake and eat it too look he causes
sweetheart and stuff like that
sit down sweetheart I would be I'd be a
lot nicer or you're right there it is
there in the things belly cuz that's a
mouth that's no cave that's no moon yeah
there's your sand worm if you walk with
us so this thing you can't do this thing
sleeps with its mouth open then because
they [ __ ] flew right into it and it
didn't even notice so it must have been
fly through teeth it must have been
sleeping lucky huh huh and [ __ ] the
ship flew right in yeah here's day two
of only three days of training it takes
to be a Jedi apparently and that
training is more of a physical workout
than anything else right it's like run
around with me on your back do some
flips
alright so every Kirchner's a
directorial career there's a lot of TV
in the front end of it [ __ ] like philip
marlowe and the rebel canes hundred
naked city Kraft suspense theatre the
return of a man called horse then he
does the eyes of Laura Mars is 1978
horror movie then oh what have I done
away they got away in that movie Empire
that never seen ever again
then episode of Amazing Stories Robocop
2 and his last credit is an episode of
Seaquest 2032 in 1993 he directed
Robocop 2 that's right I remember yeah
I'm like you would think like not for
nothing but if today he's a dude who
comes on and directs a [ __ ] giant
Star Wars movie like the sky's the limit
for you after that you know like if he's
the [ __ ] Rousseau's you know like
what else you want to do man what do you
we got giant franchises over here we got
franchises over there I'm gonna do a
fast and furious when I do whatever like
you said dude who then went from there
to like the kind of off Brian James Bond
movie and then television and then
Robocop 2 and then it feels like there
should have been a trajectory as opposed
to a gentle decline which is too bad now
you know listen I've seen this movie a
lot I've seen this I bet you an awful
lot dig about just it always bores the
[ __ ] out of me man like you know I love
this man I agree this is my least
favorite aspect is Dagobah it's just
like a move-on man except when he comes
face to face with Darth Vader in the in
the tree but we get a lot of that later
on in the movie so and this one isn't
even real Darth Vader it's like are you
out of vision so even then I was like
this sequence blows I mean yes - I loved
Yoda as a kid so I was happy to watch it
but in retrospect it's the least
interesting ass but yeah that's right
he's in training I mean think about it
was the Rey stuff in last Jedi her
training more compelling because there's
no conflict there really either yeah I
mean but it's not it's not like a kind
of 20 minute which is dropping anchor
for this guy to go away to sleepaway
camp and learn how to be a Jedi you know
they don't do that with Rey even in in
in you know as a Skywalker that's just
like a 5 minute she's running through
the forest stuff where this isn't it
this is the middle of the movie for your
protagonist and he's just kinda like
he's convincing an old guy - you know
climb on his back and run through the
freakin jungle and then this when he
actually does get to face-to-face with
with Darth Vader is kind of cool but
it's not the driving force of the
sequence and so every time I've seen it
since like when I went to the theater
and saw the special editions when I saw
them again when they had like as a
marathon before rising Skywalker I kind
of not often this part man like you know
it's weird to me as he's running around
with no shirt on and then he gets he
owed off his back and then he's like I'm
gonna go in the tree
puts his jacket on he gets dressed to do
that like who puts their jacket on after
they're running around they're all over
eating [ __ ] and you're gonna go
underground but all is forgiven because
holy [ __ ] man this is mam in the minimum
and the minimum is slow-mo slow-mo
[Laughter]
who draws first two lights out Luke's is
already lit yeah and then the other pole
sucking around here because this fader
is not the Vader from rogue one I mean
it granted it's only a vision because
look how quickly Luke wins oh he cut his
[ __ ] head off that's the only time I
mean well the who gets decapitated Count
Dooku that's oh and George George was in
charge of that trilogy man what a metal
choice to have him cut his head off even
though it was just a vision but they
didn't make it real clear that it was
just a vision when I was a kid like
watch what happens at the end of the
sequence man like [ __ ] the cut to
Yoda and he's like playing with a stick
and [ __ ] but it's not like Luke comes
out and he goes holy [ __ ] I saw a vision
of my dad like there's nothing there
there's like literally nothing happens
in that [ __ ] seat like he sees this
thing oh [ __ ] all that because here come
the Bounty Hunter's man yes yes
Oh [ __ ] this this world-building son
of a [ __ ] Lucas was a genius just threw
in characters you never even [ __ ]
around with beyond this scene man yeah
and I was willing to buy figures boss
and there's 4-lom it would make the
world so much bigger and it's so easy
which is like who are all these they're
all badasses just bounty hunters in this
universe this is super [ __ ] cool I
gotta go all these figures who's that
guy and that guy was that guy dude that
guy whoa
it's Jon Jon Favreau was so smart to
bring Eiji 11 into it cuz I loved ig-88
you never got enough backstory on them
there's another bounty hunter in there
dude a human dude who's all [ __ ] up
called dengar you don't get a lot of
screen time [ __ ] no but that was it that
bounty hunter scene is that [ __ ]
quick man and it
such an impact on me and a lot of people
as a kid you know Boba Fett gets a
little more screen time but like it was
so cool man and you were elect for the
rest of the movie please do it again go
back show us more [ __ ] bodyguards as
a feeling work I felt bad for as a kid
for Han Solo that his [ __ ] car
wouldn't start all the time like I was
always like what a [ __ ] bummer man
like everyone's looking to you for
[ __ ] like you gotta save us and you
know and I got this cool ride and
everything but yeah but I don't have no
brakes but still I just I knew a lot of
Han Solo's in my hometown of Highlands
New Jersey man none of us had a [ __ ]
cherry chip right everyone had a kind of
broken-down beater and stuff like that
so you know i you know Princess Leia
she's not used to working around ships
that break down and [ __ ] you know she
comes from money but like you know this
pauper and [ __ ] he's like I'm lucky I
got a spaceship at all and [ __ ] so I
think my where I was born and how I was
raised
made me feel for Han Solo man I bet she
had a little bit of like you know not
shame but like embarrassment like as my
[ __ ] car well you know it works and
it saved your [ __ ] life didn't it him
more than once I do like that like him
in charging at the Star Destroyer even
though he's he's moving into Attack
Position is the like I'm in the
spaceship equivalent of Han Solo running
around the corner on the Death Star
just screaming at the top of his lungs
with blasters chasing after his
stormtroopers like here's more I mean
based on all this [ __ ] we could be
Jedi's you know I'm sorry you know I
mean I can't I can't do the rock I could
put rocks on top of other rocks and I
could do a handstand if you put a puppet
on my feet I'll be okay with that
yeah like guns oh [ __ ] he's [ __ ] Yoda
coming oh the last time we saw Luke use
the Force he barely got his lightsaber
out of the ice on Hoth which like was
two days ago
and that was an oppressor to any
president that was [ __ ] stuck
in rocks and doing headstands and [ __ ]
like this is two three weeks into
training this is not like the day after
nevermind that his teacher wants him to
lift a [ __ ] a whole plane look you
know if I'm Luke I'm like you're not
impressed with the rocks like [ __ ] like
hallways with you what cannot be done
yeah this is where he drops wisdom this
is where it gets all kung fu on them and
[ __ ] like that
but as a kid that didn't really sink in
first buing I didn't walk out of Empire
Strikes Back going like I feel wizard
[Laughter]
man you told me yeah take some real good
life advice man instead I walked out of
this movie going the [ __ ] gonna happen
a han will they save ha like never mind
what happened before that's what struck
me most this movie was the end game of
its time the way that like people
[ __ ] screamed at the theater and
[ __ ] interacted and there were big
epic moments and [ __ ]
this movie was absolutely full of those
as well man feel-good wonderful moments
[ __ ] shocking moments big losses
their actual stakes I mean I guess it's
more like infinity war because the
infinity war all the bad [ __ ] happens
and whatnot but it is the high bar by
which every screenwriter or every
[ __ ] pop culture fans always like Wow
or certainly every Star Wars fan is like
well is it as good as empire dot BBC
just did an article recently I think it
was BBC on like you know is that part
really all that I don't think so and I
didn't bother reading because I'm like
look I don't know much in life but I
know this is a damn near perfect movie
if not the perfect movie so come at it
and you come at me ya know there's
there's definitely like hot take theater
has seemed to give birth to a bunch of
people who have never seen like I'm 12
years old and now I'm watching a thing
that you loved when you were 12 years
old you know what it's not so good and I
think
[ __ ] you Justin oh yeah like context I
don't know if you I don't know if you've
noticed mark sometimes to take going
into adulthood to see this kind of
symbolism in a movie I'm pretty sure
that the puppet is talking about Jesus
really I mean he's like he's in the rock
he's in the tree he's in the air look
over there I mean that's like so I sold
Jesus as a kid so I mean it sounds more
dr. Seuss to me than Jesus
is it a rock is it a clock is it a bear
is it over there I mean I always do a
lot of holy books sound very Seussian
when you break this guy with the cane
and she you know in a in a modern take
on Yoda at one point he would [ __ ]
pull the cane apart and it would have a
like light up like saber and me like why
the [ __ ] do you think I carried this
forever yeah this is a huge you know and
I think this seems a little too long
mark I'll be honest with you I'm not a
great filmmaker myself so I got no
business criticizing but too long for
the Yoda puppet lifting the x-wing out
of the they really pulled the taffy on
this this needed this be about half the
length of what it is that wouldn't stand
in the current movie people be like move
on hurry the [ __ ] up get back on what
you would have wanted to do is like you
want to cut away from Luke failing go do
something else and then you cut back in
you're just left in it just so it's not
a 12 minute scene but it saved by eight
[ __ ] the Yoda flex of you know you
couldn't do it watch me [ __ ]
and then the score like this John
Williams bit of music this that John
Williams is just [ __ ] killing this
you know John Williams to was just like
whoosh yet leave that in that gives me
something cool to [ __ ] score like
that's the star of this long-ass [ __ ]
sequence with him lifting the x-wing out
of the water is that score and then of
course we did this later on and Raisa
Skywalker remember in last Jedi he
wouldn't lift it out of the water but
rod Skywalker didn't he lifts some ship
out of the water and [ __ ] um he even
though he's dead yes force ghost does
not allowed his old
Red five standing by oh look at that's
cold that's cold Yoda he's like that is
why you fail fail ma'am in a minute
minute loser loser member you are
canceled this [ __ ] like you just
go what he wants to work for Darth Vader
man like forget it if I worked for Darth
Vader at quick stop I wouldn't elastin a
day he would have been choking me out
right away
no Imperial business management skills
leave something to be desired
this is probably the most immature
thought I'll have about this movie mark
but I want to share it with you please
if you're somebody who's about to get
choked to death by Darth Vader don't you
think your last move is too quick tug
one out no you're gonna die anyway
you've seen him choke people out Oh jam
my hand on my dying ecstasy I wouldn't
stop you be like what is he doing is he
no even polish I tell you man my action
would cut his legs out from under him
harder harder harder core than obi-wan
did it just never tell Vader bad news
just like yeah
everything's fine everything's great I'm
gonna I'm talked to lieutenant Johnson
over here I'm everything's great by me
never talk I like to I like the fact
that you know he's like we're gonna
float away with the [ __ ] garbage they
just shut this guy off so they can maybe
make out and she does is so [ __ ] so
[ __ ] up well he's even more [ __ ] up
as when they start [ __ ] they turn him
back on so he can watch - I c-3po this
is uh like done she's she's like she's
about to oh they're at Lando the
Atlantis sister Lando system ah that's
no system he's a man he sure is man he's
the man that made my mom go see this
movie he's a card card click Ehlinger
saw that
he's uh he's Donald Glover for heaven's
sakes yeah but now the cinematography
and the scene is great just look at this
the blues and the yellows and it's
gorgeous they go to a mining colony with
the [ __ ] of a mining just err because
they say it's kind of gas so they just
are they because they're not connected
to anything they're floating in the
goddamn sky yeah it's like they're in
[ __ ] like Saturn or Jupiter whatever
you know to use regular terrestrial
ideas but I guess they're yeah it's gas
mining it seems we're just pulling it
from the air so when Luke goes sliding
down the tube and [ __ ] here look look
she's gonna give him a [ __ ] kiss and
you know this dude is looks like you
went running like what what's a story
morning glory do you like me no he like
me I don't know if I was him I would not
be bitching at c-3po I turn him back on
and be like he'd be my buddy that I'd be
like what do I do
does this girl even like me does she
ever talk about me I heard you say
earlier that you were in her bedroom
back on HOF and [ __ ] like the
temperatures so like you know her like
you've been around or you were around
that circular table when we went in Ward
in the stars oh it's the mandalorian
version oh there he is man he's
definitely had Mandalorian I would
imagine I mean like Banda or is he is
Boba Fett mando seems to have a code and
you know of good guy at the end of the
day but MoMA Fett codeless yeah I mean
it doesn't seem as if Boba Fett is
following the way he seems like he's
lost the way how long before they
reference Boba Fett on the Mandalorian
you think oh if it's not you know all
over season two it feels as if it's uh
it's a wasted opportunity at some point
really got it got at least a reference
to may have somebody talked about the
one that got eaten by a Sarlacc and then
lay a little track and be like I always
heard he got out so that he could
[ __ ] mando versus Boba and [ __ ] like
that oh dude you know that is the season
finale of season two jon favreau you
listening he's like no I'm not being
creative in making I'm setting the
[ __ ] tones of pop culture you think
I'm listening to your [ __ ] podcast we
shot season three in my backyard
[Laughter]
this is where Luke is all of a sudden
like all right I gotta go I saw the
future see why didn't they kill two
birds with one stone and have him seen
the future inside the tree you know what
I'm saying
you'd have thought like he could have
had a vision of them at that dinner
table and be like oh my god they all
went to dinner without me
holy [ __ ] Darth Vader's there like
instead of doing a poetic thing like him
fighting Darth Vader and then finding
out that he's fighting himself yeah now
Yoda strong he's got the force he can
[ __ ] keep this guy here but he's cool
he's just like look how come stay later
pray if you want to go be my guest just
know that three days there's not a Jedi
make and yet in the [ __ ] another movie
like in Return of the Jedi like guys a
joke you came back one of the cheapest
Star Wars vehicles that you can buy as
the Kenner toy collection was the twin
pod cloud car mark barnard initially
nine yeah - guys $5.99
it had no beeping lights and just had
stickers you could apply and open
windows so you could put the figures in
and landing gear but still like any
relative could give it could get you a
Star Wars toy because they had plenty of
Bespin twin pod cloud cars on the two
guys Bradley's okay mark and you know be
like look I'm interested I know what
you're interested in and [ __ ] so I had
maybe four five twin pod cloud cars and
[ __ ] because it is the go-to cheap gift
I guess it was on sale for like 399 so I
got a fleet of them like nobody thinks
to get me a TIE fighter I don't have one
of the those were expensive because they
beeped and [ __ ] the wings popped off
and [ __ ] here we are our best Ben here's
some new CG [ __ ] because none of this
was in the og yellow land wine for me
the lady would you let everything else
and it was enough and we liked it oh
yeah he used he used this [ __ ] in
addition to beef it up and and bespin
suddenly looks vast and stuff like that
yeah a lot like course on your
absolutely
right yeah man I want to know is anybody
know out there how do you mind guess
from the air because there's no
connection to a planet or anything like
that
there's no only hovering there yeah so
they must be mining it from the air
gases in the air and [ __ ]
so when leuco slidin down does he is he
choking on gas down there where he's
just like it straight up to Madagascar
oxygen and would he keep falling would
he keep falling into the center of a
planet or is the gap exactly is the gas
so heavy it might have caught him if you
were to let go and here comes the
greatest character and [ __ ] Empire
Strikes Back Lobot the guy behind landed
the ball guy who gave every ball guy in
America hope that they too could be in a
Star Wars movie they got saw that guy
show up and they were like that's me
I'm Lobo and he's got bones and [ __ ]
he's got his headphones on his Sony
Walkman here's a in advance and [ __ ]
Moorhead did he pop up in anything else
recently I don't know [ __ ] is he in is
he in the ginger slice right I heard
there was a that they wanted to have him
in rise a Scott Walker and maybe he got
cut for time or something but that would
have been a deep cuts [ __ ] reference
if Lando was like still hanging out with
Lobot and you're like he's a [ __ ] bald
manservant with the headphone is Lobot a
human or cyborg are those things just
you know his like [ __ ] air traffic
controller headphones or is he half-man
half-machine mmm is he like Robocop is
he Westworld is he a host whoo-hoo
crossover once again everybody leaving
c-3po behind even though he's the only
one that could speak every [ __ ]
language so you're gonna run into a
bunch of ugh knocks you don't want that
[ __ ] guy around cuz you ain't gonna
know and he's like [ __ ] I have spoken
and walks away and [ __ ] like that well
the one language that he can't speak is
a language of love because Landers about
to go [ __ ] Princess Leia and I don't
need my cannon look how he's doing it
take notes kids he's not even walking
next to her he's leaving her in the dust
just walking with Han he's like I'm
gonna play my move by not being
interested innards but he's got a lot
cape wins all that's true yes maybe why
he's walking in front he's showing off
the ass view and the cape and she's
sitting there going cape man cuz she
comes from like cape world to some
degree right yeah you know and then
again the other cape that she saw was
Vader's cape but it's like ooh this
guy's rock have a nice cape each you
tell that [ __ ] cursed him in
Hatice that other Threepio unit and how
weird that I you know a c-3po sees
another Threepio unit and like [ __ ]
they don't hang out and [ __ ] but I walk
my dog all the time it's a dachshund and
we see other dachshunds and she don't
give a [ __ ] so I guess this tracks is
what I'm saying whatever you're a
goldish I don't give a [ __ ] no but it's
like you we've never seen another c-3po
in this movie and this guy isn't like
hey we should hang out and the other one
isn't like hey we should where are you
from holy [ __ ] isn't it hard being
surrounded by all these people who don't
take us seriously they always leave us
behind they shut us down
have you ever gotten shut down in the
middle of a [ __ ] conversation [ __ ]
like that but instead my [ __ ] walks
away and he gets killed for it gets
punished let that learn you something
and now there's a killer ghost vision
seems very clear I don't remember it
being that clear as a kid like it's no
longer a force ghost he looks like he's
in the scene with them he's just well
lit yeah I guess so I guess that's what
they did for the special edition do you
think when Luke's not around that Ghost
Kenobi and Yoda hang out I mean I think
so because whatever the [ __ ] do they
have to do like what what does if I
wasn't yet I do if I was in heaven I'd
come back all the time and hang out with
people I'm not scaring him but like the
ones that have the shining like [ __ ]
Yoda apparently does so we can talk to
the dead I could come hang out with them
all the time and stuff I mean you know
heavens eternal they say and she just
keeps going he's dead you're dead
forever so yeah and you live for such a
long time you know on earth how would
you not be interested in what's going on
and [ __ ] is out with them all the time
I'm sure he's notice the sketch
brothers - yes I bet you they sit around
and he's like remember when we let the
boy into the council and I told you not
to but you were like no I'm bringing the
boy and that is created nine [ __ ]
movies or more the next time you listen
to me maybe next time you'll listen to
[ __ ] yoga and he's like his why I
don't come hang out with you as a ghost
on Dagobah because you're so critical
and shitty about the past get over it
I'm dead I paid the ultimate price and
Yoda's like I don't think so
the ultimate price is give me one of
them Twix bars that I stole good so like
if I remember correctly is it returned
yeah he he Brit he doesn't break his
promise right Luke goes bad does Vaughn
return the Jedi but is it going on who's
the first one who learns or is it
obi-wan who learns how to commune with
the dead Ryan is that is that at the end
of like Revenge of the Sith where it's
like you know your old master is waiting
for you I can teach you how to talk to
the dead and like so now obi-wan learns
it and then teaches everybody else or
does Yoda know like who's teaching
[ __ ] how to talk with dead
ghosts who do you think he referenced
Yoda when he was like you know all is
lost and he goes no that boy was our
last hope and Kenobi says he goes no
there is another who in this movie who
did George Lucas and Lawrence Kasdan
Leigh Brackett intend as the other you
know I I would bet you dollars to donuts
they didn't know I neveri I think they
were punting the ball to the next
they're like let's leave ourselves a
little present and we'll say there's
another Jedi out there we'll figure out
how it's gonna be somebody hears so many
new character but it's a cool thing to
make somebody think about in the three
years between movies who's the other one
who could it be
I tell you man when I was a kid all I
would think about is a massive fan of
the Star Wars movies in a massive Carrie
Fisher fan was like did they have sex
like I saw him kiss but did they have
sex I think that's why I like force
awakens so much
I was like prove the kylo Ren and [ __ ]
there's the guy he's like I have spoken
oh I am spoken all of us have spoke I'm
going to kill this what we've spoken I'm
like like accident sucking retcon they
retcon the [ __ ] ignites and brought
him back that's why I bet you we may see
Tontons next season in Mandalorian man
because they seem to go for like deep
cut poles and [ __ ] and that ugh not that
[ __ ] mando hangs out with that was
such a deep cuts pole [ __ ] what's his
name who did his voice Reggie oh we
brothers we partner friends why don't
they do a special edition of this of
Empire where they get Nick Nolte to vote
voice all the ugh knots in that room so
you know they just get the line once and
duplicate it
I went season three of Mandalorian to go
and find the old wizened one-armed wampa
that's still on off just like let me
tell you a story kid he's like and
that's when I went vegan kids today my
[ __ ] food
I want plant-based this is leading to
one of the greatest moments in Star Wars
history and the greatest unfilmed scene
in Star Wars history man you don't you
weren't seeing this coming as you were
sitting there in the movie theater all
this extra scope that you're saying that
came from George Lucas in the special
edition it was all white walls in our
best bit when we were random window no
yeah but watch the moment these doors
open
holy [ __ ] it still has the same effect
on me that it did as a kid it's an
almost Kubrick Ian shot of Darth Vader
sitting at the end of a long [ __ ]
table Han Solo's first instinct is to
[ __ ] shoot him it's like as if the
doors open and somebody was like it's
[ __ ] Hitler and Han Solo was like
holy [ __ ]
and he's like louder she's like yeah
like oh wait without question he [ __ ]
tries to kill this
- man and then Vader uses the force and
stops it but what happens next
do they eat Vader sitting down yeah like
does he take off his helmet does he
force them to watch him eat with that
[ __ ] up corroded head or he aims
falling out of his mouth he's like don't
move cuz I can still magic the [ __ ] out
of you I wish they would do that scene
never mind [ __ ] you know they're
always like what will save Star Wars or
something like that what will keep Star
Wars going give us a modern version of
the Star Wars Christmas special and give
us that scene you know Luke who's coming
to dinner good authority that Vader
doesn't eat really he processes all of
his food by his armor it's like a steel
suit so how cruel he sat there while
they all [ __ ] ate and was just like
don't worry about me I gave up eating
when you're [ __ ] buddy your buddy
your buddy's friend [ __ ] cut my legs
off on a lot of planet who's who here's
friends with Ben Kenobi Khan's like I
mean I I met him I called him an old man
he was an old man the leg cut an old
[ __ ] man I hate his guts anyway yes
please no intermittent fasting you all
please continue don't mind me he's like
I'm on a 20/4 hour fast my feeding
window is four hours Chuy put in [ __ ]
uh they were doing some [ __ ] torture
porn with Chewie man run in that book
the alarm and [ __ ] and her cuz he's like
a space dog it's cuz he's a space dog
his ears it probably hurts his ears even
more and [ __ ] this is badass [ __ ] I
wish they would make this as a replica I
wrote that [ __ ] into the original
version of Mallrats - Brody was being
[ __ ] tortured on this table a table
and it was a replica from [ __ ] show
sideshow replica life-size look Lobot
again man he's in the background I
always look at his puffy shirt like he's
got the puffiest [ __ ] shirt - that's
true man he's Seinfeld before Seinfeld
happened if they were brave enough back
in that
Infeld episode they wouldn't have called
it a pirate shirt they would have been
like that's a Lobot shirt a model show
today would totally plant that flag and
call it the Lobot sure cuz they're like
everybody knows the reference here's
where a Lando gets a little choking
himself man like you don't hit him hard
but he gives him the [ __ ] impression
of like I can't [ __ ] with you and [ __ ]
ah he was getting worse all the time
yeah and meanwhile like [ __ ] Boba
Fett who we met for like one second on
the bridge of that Star Destroyer get
more and more screentime and as a as a
kid seeing Boba Fett with Darth Vader
with stormtroopers you're like everyone
in masks ma'am and the man it's like a
sea of dr. Doom's man look Chuy's not
stupid why the [ __ ] does he put his head
on backwards he's a [ __ ] he can fix a
spaceship he can do what kinds of cool
like you know how his head goes Chewie
you just being an that's all about this
I love Hans performance here man where
he's like I don't feel so good I feel
terrible I feel those two stormtroopers
I would like to have a conversation with
those guys and [ __ ] the two that like
dropped him on the floor and walked off
it's like mm-hmm
you know you you're having them on your
shoulder you couldn't just drag them and
[ __ ] you showing care until you get to
the door and then he like always got
friends in here and you know when they
left when one of them was like you know
we didn't have to do it that way it
don't have to be this way man
he's a shutup aiders here he's watching
watches every day this is uh
get out of here Orlando this is uh I
love this as a kid because like betrayal
and [ __ ] intrigue and [ __ ] like
they they thought he was his friend but
like he's a double agent like I've seen
that in more movies and stuff like that
this is what I'm also like and it is
some Casablanca [ __ ] I'm liking more and
more how handsy she's getting with han
solo she's always got her hands on him
now and [ __ ] but still no other kiss
until you know
we get into the carbon freezing chamber
they were very stingy with the [ __ ]
kisses in this movie right like they
kissing the ship once and then they kiss
right before he goes into the cart and
freezing unit but I mean George didn't
understand how kisses work well I mean
everything can't be blamed on George
apparently Irvin Kershner had
difficulties with it as well yeah but
it's very chaste like for a romance you
know it's it's very like I wish my
bedroom was look like this but if
Annette if it did it wouldn't be this
cool ass angle from below man find a way
from the other bedroom in which every
angle is from underneath and as [ __ ]
Darth Vader walks around talking all
those ugh knots are like I have spoken I
have I have spoken he's choking them all
out for disrespect and they're like
that's just what they say they're
hugging our nuts when they it's like
period at the end of a sentence it
didn't mean disrespect
please don't choke out our ugh knock
crew dude [ __ ] is gonna run a
carbon-freezing unit not for nothing but
robot robot has more screen time than
Boba Fett and there is a parallel
universe in which Lobot was a character
that we all kind of fetishized and built
up in our heads it's the universe I live
in every day man I love Lobot I guess
but like Globo what a great shot iconic
shot of them walking up the gangplank I
get high on Lobot that's all I'm gonna
say Lobot also like you know there's a
whole [ __ ] movie behind the movie you
could do with his character and [ __ ]
like what's he doing behind the scenes
you know I'm sure the actor is like you
know I'm sure the audience wants to know
what Lobot is doing so we should
probably tell they're like oh really we
should call Marvel and we should listen
I know you guys are in the Star Wars
comics business we would like to do a
Lobot miniseries let me tell you I can
sell the [ __ ] out of a low bar comma
Darth leave [ __ ] boba fett almost
[ __ ] shot the [ __ ] out of Chewie I
love the scene when I was a kid man this
is like they are best friends because
he's oh in that shop she looks at Bader
look at that shot he's like I hate this
space prick he came at me so hard in the
last movie I ain't seen him since we
blew up his big [ __ ] round stupid
house and [ __ ] and here he is mere feet
away from me and [ __ ] but I love this
friendship and love oh Ken Smith 10 9 10
years old that was everything I wanted
that to be the whole [ __ ] this movie
built Who I am today man romance
friendship like he's telling his boy
like no no no now's not the time you've
got to protect the princess and [ __ ] and
these [ __ ] are like we have spoken
and walking away try to get in and the
best two lines in movie history I love
you I know so [ __ ] good I wonder if
there's another version of the
screenplay where that conversation was
like you know two pages long you know in
the same way that the fugitive
apparently had a huge like three page
scene between Tommy Lee Jones and
Harrison Ford we're in the movie it says
I didn't kill my wife
and time of the gem says I don't care
okay I don't care but it had been this
whole long speech between them and those
two guys just cut it this is all that
it's about and so I wonder if there's a
version of the screenplay where it's I
love you but there's no way we can be
together because yeah I'm a princess but
it is goundrill if there is the common
factor is Harrison Ford who's like I
want to do three pages of dialogue he's
like we had this trick worked on Empire
I want one of these giant claws these
[ __ ] you know the claw to pick me up
out of bed early I wanna sleep on a
Carbonite looking bed that's why you
know kids want a race car beds
I wanna my bed to be look like a car
block of Carbonite with those lights on
the side and [ __ ] and then I just lay
there at night and I sleep like this and
then [ __ ] just push you around
the house like we're gonna get breakfast
now yeah all right let's go good
breakfast han Solo like that's a
defensive pose right where he's just
is that my defensive pose would be like
my [ __ ] around my head or to be like
I'll suck your dick to pull me out of
the carbon freeze they'd find me like
that's what I do is it real [ __ ] you to
them I'd do some of this [ __ ] found
weird wouldn't ya the carbon the carbon
freezing process
I assume breaks them off and look man
this [ __ ] had the audacity to
call Luke Skywalker he goes up to Darth
Vader he goes Skywalker has landed in
[ __ ] Darth Vader's all about the last
names he calls Luke Skywalker he calls
Lando Calrissian well because first
names of dudes were friendly yeah it's
true he's keeping it he's keeping it
real he's like look we're keeping a pro
here such a great scene such a great set
insanely well lit and they get a lot of
use out of this set when they were
budgeting they'll yeah that moment
between boys when he's like [ __ ] up
right when they were budget in this
movie you know they were like look can
we reuse that carbon freezing chamber
for the [ __ ] lightsaber fight mix
that's gonna be a big like oh yeah we
got this Luke around the shot when I was
a kid he's just bombing around [ __ ]
Cloud City this is like walking around
Manhattan and nobody's there you know
what I'm saying this is like kovin
[ __ ] country it's very cool place is
very quarantine it's very like easiest
tool around Century City and like
everything is all white and pretty where
is everybody oh he's sick
meanwhile you got the loudest [ __ ]
droid in the world who's gonna get you
killed on an empty hallway oh [ __ ] Boba
Fett taking a shot Boba Fett like do you
think Boba Fett flew around for the next
you know a few months and was like I
almost [ __ ] shot Luke Skywalker
thinks he's a little bit she's a punk I
don't care about him and now here comes
Lando with his [ __ ] his swatch the
one that plugin I'm gonna give to mark
he's got Apple watch and he's [ __ ]
Sarah test his Texas is checking the
globe ah exactly oh [ __ ] and look Lando
has this look where he's like who is
that guy cuz he doesn't know [ __ ]
Luke is yeah when she I love
look see that look for exactly the [ __ ]
is I don't know Lucas but I love when
she's like Lok it's a trap awesome we
did that we stole that Amol rats where
you know they're like Renee Renee James
saw Bob hurry when he's being dragged
past I [ __ ] love this oh this movie
starts like look all of its great but as
a kid you know now we're done with
[ __ ] like the little green guy little
Saints firing [ __ ] that you like get
back to the [ __ ] wars and the stars
and this is where it all starts coming
together man and our heroes have been
broken up like they always say you can't
do that with your heroes and movies they
always say like [ __ ] like in last
Jedi they were like oh they should have
kept [ __ ] Finn and Rey and and Poe
together but they didn't do it here and
Empire Strikes Back
these [ __ ] barely had any time
together like one scene in the hospital
ward before they're all separated and
then they never get to be together again
for the whole [ __ ] movie that was the
closest where Hans frozen and lay is
there and he's there it's crazy they
seemed look at that oh my god so I
convinced my wife to let me design a
house that looks just like this room
it's impossible will never happen but
like I would can my office bill I'll
tell you what if you have a dog it would
hide a lot of dog [ __ ] stepping in [ __ ]
and then it gets into the grading and
[ __ ] try digging dog [ __ ] out of that
metal mark that's a nightmare like that
all that polishing then you're
definitely getting yourself a
housekeeper because you keep keeping
that up I don't think so yeah what are
you doing just buffing out this [ __ ]
floor again and you're constantly
running a smoke machine which is we all
know you know that stuff's not good to
be ingesting on a regular basis and
stuff no I know but then it don't look
like this then it's like oh this looks
it's like when you see Batman's costume
in daylight how come Darth Vader's
costume still works in daylight yeah the
best been soldiers man the best been uh
I had those figures as well the best
many regulars we got this look how happy
low body is he's so self-satisfied and
shitty like he had a big smile on his
face
like [ __ ] these guys do you think that
they take him and kill those
stormtroopers or do they just put them
in a closet somewhere just stay here
don't make any noises beep I'll be right
back oh oh look at this this is so
awesome and she was like [ __ ] you you
killed my boy this is what he should
have done to [ __ ] kylo Ren after he
took on solo she should have choked the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of that piece of [ __ ]
was the Diltz it was back Biggs still
time to say ha it sounds like head yeah
we speak English [ __ ]
mispronounces him everyone else she's
like Han and c-3po making apologies for
his friends man oh cool the shots in the
movie man when you were a kid you were
like look look at his ship slave 1 they
only showed it this shot and when it
takes off and they still made a toy of
it and sold that to him that toy came
with the only Han Solo in carbonite
action figure wasn't a real figure it
was just a piece of plastic and then
later on they made a figure that you
could pull out of the carbon I wasn't
quite I always I always wanted that Han
Carbonite coffee table yes but that also
feels a little morbid unless like that's
your jam we're like I want a frozen dude
and then put glass and like rest my
drinks on but still unleaded to see a
good coffee table would be like frozen
Jar Jar oh look how sad she is man like
there he goes that good D that I was
looking for he's my hero off he goes
there goes my hero
and then she's right back into the Star
War I find her character compelling his
[ __ ] man because she's royalty but she's
also like for as long as we see her in
all these movies a [ __ ] soldier do
you see him give the [ __ ] point and
get Lucan this where's look you piece of
[ __ ] Vader doing a dive man like [ __ ]
that counts as action back in 1980
that's the bait of
ro1 the guy that's like I'm gonna jump
at you and [ __ ] but even if no one he
was more tough than this yeah like I by
late fall promotion to general you know
like as you see that [ __ ] you see her
holding guns shooting at people like
planning strategy talking to her men
like yeah for sure
but even when she's got like you know
all she sees her love take off she
doesn't even get time to mourn man she's
like back out at pew pew pew pew she's a
fighter a warrior her whole life she was
fighting except for like to move the
period between the movies when they had
the baby I guess when a guy low-rent
most impressive could you imagine you're
fighting Darth Vader and you use like a
fire extinguisher in his face like
that's your big [ __ ] move and it kind
of works because he's like oh my
breathing flipped for nineteen eighty
that [ __ ] flip sent me to like
gymnastics classes I was like because I
want to flip to like Luke Skywalker is
flipping around teach me how to do that
[ __ ] they never really could but I still
was how on earth does this Mary Sue get
the upper hand on Darth Vader I'm asking
you kicked him on [ __ ] platform he'd
add two and a half days of training
marking some time it's Darth Vader off
the platform
Rhett Cod rat God that shot of him in
the tunnel looks so cool in so many
pre-product
pre-release shots in many cards
let's see kids oh this great scene is
where he breaks the window and [ __ ] but
when when we were young we couldn't just
like oh the movie comes out you know in
three months and streaming or whoo the
movie comes out on video in [ __ ] a
year or something like that you relived
the adventure primarily through Star
Wars cards and I had all the Empire
Strikes Back cards man and that all this
artwork like that stills for everything
and stuff and I remember him in that
tunnel that was one of the big pictures
and stuff don't you collect the cards
mark I had the cards I had like the
photo books they also put out that had
like 20-30 pages it just stills from it
you'd get like your Starlog magazine
back in the day and just
look at all these pictures but yeah I
would just like to point out that this
lightsaber battle is so basic I could
have directed it and did in Jay and
Silent Bob strike back my blunt Sabre
fight is about as [ __ ] active as this
fight so you know I'm not an action
visionary man I just do what I see and
that's what I saw growing up I was like
this counts as action and it was action
[ __ ] anyway he says that ain't an action
scene man just because it don't have a
zillion cuts to it cuz Michael Bay
didn't fit 100 cuts in there still we've
all seen that video online where they
take the Star Wars scene with Ben Kenobi
and the guy [ __ ] recreates it and
it's legit oh you should have seen this
too
I've never seen the behind the scenes of
that sequence it was maybe the first
behind-the-scenes thing I'd ever seen in
my entire life and they just show you
all of the crew hands off camera
throwing things at Mark Hamill he's like
this was added that shot of people in
the hallway this big exterior all that
[ __ ] was added man took away from land
oh he was just it was a close-up of him
talking mostly yeah she's unnecessary
you know and then like the dude who had
to do the running jump backwards through
the things like oh this is how you do it
I kind of don't want to know how you do
it cuz it's cooler head of it is using
his mind this is what la is gonna look
like when they lift the quarantine
[ __ ] run and I was running in the
hallways and everybody loses their Cape
like what happened Lando's Kate see that
you know that [ __ ] resort that
they're building and [ __ ] they should
the old one that's best been themed
because look you know windows you know
you just walk around inside and be
inside the attraction you know never
interacting with the with the real world
you know they're doing that with their
hotels putting in winter you know you
could see the [ __ ] stars and [ __ ] I
demand a bespin Hotel it'll be the
underground I'm gonna I'm gonna I got a
hot take can I share how take with you
please do
I don't like Leah Princess Leia's buns
Leia buns as much as I like her hair in
this sequence in in Empire Strikes Back
I'm more partial to the Leia hair from
this movie that was when I fell in love
with both Princess Leia and Carrie
Fisher Star Wars
not so much but this movie this strong
woman man who had this soft vulnerable
side who could like lead an army but
also fall for my rare notice and return
[ __ ] fire always in charge and [ __ ]
like that like this is where you know
I'm like probably every [ __ ] woman I
ever go for in my life is set by by
Princess Leia the tone is set by
Princess Leia I'm looking for Princess
Leia over and over and over again I mean
I don't I don't think like yeah yeah I
don't think that the ringlets that's
happening here but that like the hoff
little circlet of hair that's the one
yeah see it's the ringlets that I'd go
for and [ __ ] the daling hairs the hoops
the hoops if you hoopty-hoops wait so
these [ __ ] got away in quite a
similar fashion as Boba Fett did just in
time and stuff meanwhile this fight
ain't over look at these giant sets man
like you know this is blue blue screen
cuz I've seen pictures of that of like
yeah that's a that's a drawing like
that's one of those rear-projection
Jamie Jets a matte painting yes from
back in the day look at that [ __ ]
[ __ ] mover Vader just comes out of like
Chang comes out of nowhere like [ __ ]
Jack Nicholson and the shining is like
ah he puts it into Luke's chest and [ __ ]
thank you okay yeah man this is action
to me I know like nowadays it would be a
lot more going on but like that's pretty
good right there and think about it you
know while they're making this flick
they're like what a beautiful shot and
it looks like it's real like they're in
this giant place that nobody has ever
seen in a movie before don't let
yourself be destroyed as obi-wan
bloato's that says that's a trigger for
Luke Skywalker max he loved that old man
and [ __ ] that old man got him off the
planet and whatnot oh there's a moment
what the as as we said in 1980 [ __ ] just
got real
up until then high adventure in the sky
his this guy cut his [ __ ] hand off
and that was shocking enough you could
have went to credits after that and we
would all been like holy [ __ ] he cut me
loose and off what's gonna happen in the
third movie and the big shock
isn't even coming is isn't even happen
it's about to happen here the double
whammy of I will cut your [ __ ] hand
off and tell you who your father is and
guess what if he is man the power of the
dark side told me if I never told you
what happened to your father I'll get a
[ __ ] man he's right now these guys are
writing Kill Bill Vol - they are writing
every before ragnerok they're writing
every familial fantasy movie or not even
fantasy [ __ ] like that like that hole I
am your that didn't come from anything
else that I know of no it's not like oh
he stole that from [ __ ] gone with the
wind when when [ __ ] Rhett Butler was
like frankly my dear I am your father
you know really [ __ ] weird so it was
the first time in a movie where like you
were like and not even just for kids I
think for adults too I think a bunch of
adults were like well I didn't see that
coming holy [ __ ] [ __ ] and there was
no internet to spoil it and whatnot it
was nuts but yeah you know and I when I
went to see it I didn't get see Star
Wars an opening day and that secret kept
it's not like anybody told anybody or
anything like that no not at all
and you know the other thing that I
remember digging up was that David
Prowse who played you know he was in the
suit um they gave him different lines
like he didn't know that that the father
reveal oh really
yeah I wonder if they knew they were
gonna do it we're just keeping it secret
or if he was in post and somebody was
like look you don't have to loop lines
well no because they needed to so what
the [ __ ] did he said is Luke has that
reaction of no it can't be true
so he must have just been like you know
[ __ ] your dad one evil or something
like that
it was I thought he was acting too now
Prowse perhaps you spoke all of Vader's
lines during field filming was given a
false page that contained dialogue with
the revelatory line being no obi-wan
killed your father and they told ya they
told Hamill
moments just moments before the cameras
rolled on his close-up and he didn't
tell anybody including his wife and Ford
apparently didn't learn the truth until
he watched the actual movie is that
right so while they're making the movie
they didn't even know so Lucas kept that
so close to the best
yes nuts so but but Lucas had to know
when he was making the movie because he
had to tell Hamel like you're reacting
to he's your dad yeah and and Mark
Hamill's never said I didn't [ __ ] know
he said that like he knew he didn't I
don't know if he said seconds before but
he definitely found out yeah Luke using
the force to call out to Leia I remember
being like oh I don't want these two
getting back together and the sister
thing I like her in hand I'm like they
belong together sister thing hasn't been
a factor yet we still don't know that
these two are related correct
we don't although if you had to put this
sequence where he's calling out to her
and the there is another together then
like maybe Lucas was you know if you
haven't landed on it at the very least
there's more going on between them and
at least more than with her relationship
to the force then he had talked about
before that had never been in the movies
before they that shot used to just be in
an empire originally just Darth Vader
walking down the hallway with
stormtroopers going like alert my ship
I'm ready and then they did for the
extended version like an exterior shot
and [ __ ] like that but I remember being
a kid and being like that shot was so
pointless like yet him and a bunch of
stormtroopers look so cool but all he
said was like I'm leaving no more like
you know like if I would have begged
they could have looped anything into
that scene so they should have had to be
like so then I told this son of a [ __ ]
I was his dad really though really this
is dope right here man we never got to
see this part of the Falcon in many
movies where he gets to go up to his
little boom tube elevator and [ __ ] and I
love that he harnessed himself in so he
don't get [ __ ] blown away that must
have been from like the army or some
such
like something based in reality yeah
well I wonder why Leia doesn't go get
him like why would they trust I mean I
guess this is not a the vote of
confidence for Lando like you have to go
get Luke Luke who know you'd do it I
have to go fly maybe they were like
we're still not sure on Lando so if he
gets blown away up but you're right she
should have been the one that was like
I'll go get Luke he's my good friend who
I kissed sometimes so still at this
point in the movie we don't know that
they're related so I wonder when she has
the conversation with Luke to be like
hey man while we were in space I was
making out with on so stop kissing don't
kiss me anymore yeah we can't be [ __ ]
buddies anymore yeah it's done it's over
cuz I got a new guy to [ __ ] a lot but
it's it's now a hyung thing so and I
haven't had sex with him yet so don't
tell him [ __ ] look she just kissed him
again you just kissed him and like
meanwhile her other space boyfriend just
got [ __ ] ice cubed and [ __ ] like that
and still she's you don't have to like
even if you're like ah she's like
somebody's affectionate toward him I
wouldn't [ __ ] kiss somebody if they
were like beat up and [ __ ] like that
that they're missing a hand you think
they want to be kissed on the lips and
[ __ ] like that so that's not a I don't
know that he knew that they were gonna
be siblings yet mmm no I'm saying just
didn't care I was like you know what I
care was just like kiss my sister that's
how we roll in modesto bro there's
throat except the this [ __ ] my favorite
I think this is my favorite large ship
online I think my favorite small ship is
Darth Vader's TIE fighter or maybe kylo
ren's typewriter but in terms of the big
ships more than the Millennium Falcon my
hot take is I like Darth Vader's
imperial star destroyer which I think is
the executioner or the executor do you
remember what it is I think it's the
executioner which is so metal I remember
having to look that up as a kid and then
finding out what it
and I was like oh [ __ ] they name their
whole [ __ ] plane after the darkest
job in the world man taking lives away
ma'am in a minute this [ __ ]
still don't have his leg on ouch Fergus
does he register pain is that a thing I
know oh sure doing it wrong look at
Darth Vader literally looking at the
Millennium Falcon
Luke Dead he hates he hates that ship
like it left the hangar and Star Wars it
left the hangar in Hoth
it's always eluding him that [ __ ]
ship mm-hmm like most times he probably
don't know what the ships there after
looked like he's just like shoot him
down I'm gonna [ __ ] but this one he's
been intimately involved with and [ __ ]
like that so whenever he sees it he must
be like I [ __ ] hate that piece of
[ __ ] that's always causing me [ __ ] this
guy just got his hand cut off and he's
handling that trauma pretty well man I
know he's got robot cover on it [ __ ] but
I would not be that [ __ ] cool
especially when my space dad starts
talking to me in my head and [ __ ] again
like I know it's like I'll never jerk
off again because he could always pop in
and be like like the morphine event kick
in if you keep on talking to me dad
remember you cut off my second hand if
he really wants to [ __ ] with Luke right
now and he's already in his head he
could be like look to your right that is
your sister that is your second cousin
he just keeps listing all the relatives
yeah yeah or like Lucas like Ben why
don't you tell me invaders like because
I didn't want to like Ben now just me
and your dad again Ben is a lousy uncle
oh this [ __ ] he sees the ship
get away and he's like I am not long for
this world man no baiter
he just he lets him go man look at him
he's kind of like he's Charlie Brown
walking home in the snow all sad anybody
wanted but he's so bummed he forgets to
kill the [ __ ] man oh man most likely
kill you in the
look at this is there Battlestar
Galactica shot right where the whole
[ __ ] fleet is together running
through space they don't have a space
base no more because hop got blown up so
where would they be they're on their way
to where are they where's the base in in
Return of the Jedi [ __ ] I don't even
remember I just to look right because
the fleet attacks the second Death Star
it starts getting picked off and he's
like I'm afraid this battle summation is
quite operational it wouldn't make sense
that like every time they go to some
planet it always gets out it blown up or
they get caught so like listen maybe we
don't set up shop anywhere and we just
roll in space so we can just beam out
whenever we need to they gave us
everything we needed for Return of the
Jedi they literally say we will meet on
the rendezvous point at Tatooine so like
we had to know going into [ __ ] Return
of the Jedi the Tatooine was going to
play a part them saying we're gonna go
after the Bounty Hunter I don't think
they call him Boba Fett they're like
we're going after the Bounty Hunter but
they do reference Jabba the Hutt by name
first time we see [ __ ] ma'am in the
minim in the mem in a minute Luke it was
just revealed as Darth Vader's son is
becoming kind of like Darth Vader they
lean into that in the next movie in a
big bad way but here shows up this ain't
a brotherly hug this is like look once
they're gone let's toss going down that
Han is crawling south slow down I'm
telling you they still they see Luke
yeah George Lucas did not know when he
made this movie it was gonna make them
sibling there's no way I believed that
shot like they augmented that shot maybe
I'm wrong like they probably made a
better looking Saturn I think that one
the one with a falcon is like literally
going faster Milky Way that's the insert
yeah look man everyone lined up but not
victorious like in Empire Strikes Back
I remember this shot either being in the
original cut does he [ __ ] does he
don't tell me he dissolves out from this
like they'd have been in my head it was
always on their backs on the fourth yeah
do you think we're wrong and do you
think it was always like it
to the ships and then out you think
that's like a Berenstein or bernstein
bears kind of thing like we've rewritten
it in our head the mandala effect yeah
and everybody every all the kids in
Hollywood Oh Lawrence Kasdan and Leigh
Brackett because they wrote the
screenplay that everyone's been copying
for an action movie an adventure action
movie ever since everybody knows every
every creative owes so much to the
Empire Strikes Back all the little kids
in Springfield recipes everybody does I
got to say them and like think about how
how influential this film is and it
doesn't get its dick sucked nearly as
much as Star Wars everyone's always like
Star Wars a new hope but like especially
when they came out Empire did less
business than the other two and [ __ ] but
it's a it's the best Star Wars movie
hands-down and not only that but it was
the blueprint for a lot of [ __ ]
movies to come that we all fell in love
with for the rest of our lives yeah I
mean like did to your point that we
talked about early on is that there had
not been franchises like this before you
know I mean you saw plenty of the Apes
you know like yeah look tiny apes and
then you know returns and pine leaves
beneath the plant of the herbs can quit
all that stuff is you know sort of
following one another but not this way
not like these direct handoffs and not
with this sort of emotional connection
to these main characters of what's gonna
happen to these people is why you turn
in less what's gonna happen on the plan
of the Apes this movie right look at
John Ratzenberger in the credits he's
one of the rebel forces and he was also
in like Gandhi when he was a kid too I
remember he's driving a Jeep or
something like that
that guy there's the tie between Pixar
and Star Wars universe is John
Ratzenberger know I remember these color
credits my whole [ __ ] life this color
will always be the Star Wars credits
anybody could try to do [ __ ] with that
color in a movie and will always read to
me as the star was credits and when I
was in I got to be a voice and force
awakens JJ used my voice for one of the
stormtroopers i sat there I was in
Boulder Colorado watching the movie so I
was on tour doing shows and so me and
Jenn went to see Brian Skywalker like
opening-night Boulder Colorado and I
stayed through the credits and saw my
name in that blue font and boy oh boy
man every I was triggered right back in
childhood when I watched the credits for
the first time in Star Wars movies and
like that blue font was part of the
experience like it's different than
other movies I'll read these credits
there in blue and apparently Lucas got
into into a bit of a tiff with all the
various guilds because he wanted the
credits all the credits to be after the
movie you know so there's nothing
beforehand it's 20th Century Fox Lucas
from logo crawl movie and and they let
him have it for Star Wars cuz I go well
you're the writer director and you can
you know make those decisions and
whatever it be one time exclusion but
it's like no all of the movies are gonna
be that way and and so he literally like
left the DGA and the WGA
and the Motion Picture Association
because they fought him over is it well
[ __ ] it if this if this is what's gonna
be I'm gonna do that in that one way I
am like George Lucas also in the
marketing way and [ __ ] like that but uh
although he's way better but on Jay and
Silent Bob reboot I didn't have upfront
credits just a title card and then I
wanted to start the movie with the actor
credits with you know the cast with
their pictures and then do my written
and directed by after that but both
guilds the Writers Guild and the DGA got
so shitty where they were like no you
can't do that your credit has to go
before every other credit if you're not
doing mein on ends then on the back end
the writer/director credit or the
director credit has to go first so I
said fine I'll just quit the [ __ ]
guild I don't want to be a part of any
organization won't let me do what I want
to do aren't you guys here to help me
like here's me asking you to help me let
me do this [ __ ] thing where I'm not
even like I'm just want to put my cast
first man and they're like nope because
if you do it then other people will make
an argument that it can be done to other
directors and [ __ ] like that and they
held so [ __ ] firm and I was like you
know what then I'll just drop out of
this [ __ ] guilds and stuff and they
were like go ahead but you still have to
[ __ ] keep your credits the way we
told you to in this movie because it was
made
as a guild signatory film like they had
me six ways to Sunday man I was so
pissed but I couldn't just do what I
wanted to do and it wasn't me going like
I'm trying to glorify myself I was like
I just want to [ __ ] give props to the
cast first it makes more sense and flows
this way man so they're pretty pretty
tight about it man and I like I did want
to go the Robert Rodriguez and
apparently the George Lucas route of
being like [ __ ] them then I'll quit but
they were like you can quit but you're
still gonna have to keep your credits
that way [ __ ] and I was shocked I
could be not really the not really the
last thing I thought I'd be saying on an
Empire Strikes Back watch along good
oddly enough it does have a weird tie-in
to George Lucas uh your thoughts mark on
this classic that came out oh so many
years ago what is it 40 years ago this
40 years ago yeah this is the 40th
anniversary you know I still I still I
agree with you this is of of the Star
Wars movies this is the best of them I
have a love first for a new hope simply
because it was the first one but I think
this is a it's better written it's
better acted the effects are even a
quantum level better than the previous
one was even if you're not taking the
special edition to do it into
consideration but it is absolutely a
movie that introduced a generation of
film goers and eventually filmmakers to
tragedy to like what happens if your
good guys don't win you know what does a
middle chapter of a thing feel like and
it does exactly what it's supposed to do
which is like take your heroes to their
lowest point and we've lost everything
like we lost Han we lost hands like we
lost two things with ajm beginning we
found out that our dad is not our dad
like it's or our dad is our dad it's uh
it's it's kicking your characters and
balls as hard as you can and then making
them get back up from that for the
finale not only is it a movie I've
enjoyed watching throughout my life it's
a movie that I learned from even though
I don't make movies like that but we all
take from it whether we know it or not
but it's still joyful my god well as I
watched it here I was like oh man I wish
I had the volume up because [ __ ] it's
such a high adventure
film and it's still like there have been
many great Star Wars movies but this is
hands head and shoulders hands-down the
best as far as I'm concerned yes even
even with the Dagobah interlude which
could be half as long and maybe do a
little more the the stuff that surrounds
it is still fantastic young Kevin and
Mark were thrilled in a theater old
Kevin and Mark and the take about scenes
to be like move on [ __ ] this poppet
faster learn some [ __ ] there it is folks
hopefully you enjoyed yourselves
hopefully we didn't offend anybody if we
did sorry it's all in good fun and stuff
we love this movie Mindy so hopefully
you loved it along with us and stuff
indeed and yeah I'm gonna go back to my
may the fourth where I am rectifying a
long-held hole in my Star Wars knowledge
in that I never watched the Clone Wars
show so I figured that if there was a
day to begin watching the Clone Wars it
wasn't may the fourth form I may the
fourth I'm gonna barbecue some porgy no
of course not I'm vegan so I wouldn't be
barbecuing any ports and [ __ ] but I I'm
gonna celebrate today well the day is
almost done so I'm done celebrating yeah
I did my time for Star Wars man Star
Wars is in every aspect of my life
III you know it's so weird for the
amount of plugin I do for Star Wars and
[ __ ] I'm not on the payroll and I have
to pay for everything you know what I'm
saying like I bought the action figures
I buy the tickets in the movies and [ __ ]
but you do these things because you love
these things that I've loved this movie
since I was a kid and I'm delighted to
see 40 years old later it still holds up
not just as a fond childhood memory but
as a piece of cinema I mean hats off to
Irvin Kershner and crew and of course
the visionary George Lucas for giving us
this wonderful wonderful flick the great
Carrie Fisher the great Mark Hamill
Harrison Ford I've realized that I got
to like I love that movie so much as a
kid and I got to cross over with and
work with some of those people I worked
with Mark and Kerry both and Jay and
Silent Bob strike back and now I worked
with Mark again on our show masters in
the universe
I worked with Peter Mayhew came on an
episode of comic book men
I've had some crossover man with my
childhood heroes people had looked up on
the big screen and was like wow I wonder
if I'll ever meet him and stuff so this
movie laid track which I'm still you
know the industry still runs on and my
heart still runs on to this day closing
thoughts from you mr. mark barnard it's
this movie is so good it it makes me
want to watch Jedi again and like Jedi
is not a thing that I I like it quite a
bit don't love it but I like it a lot
but now I just I want to know how it
ends I want to know how it ends even
though I totally know how it ends
spoilers I can tell you this was a blast
man I enjoyed watching it with you man's
good time next time we do it in the same
room though [ __ ] this it's a little
weird yeah it's so strange I know but
strange times we can't be too
first-world about it and billing we want
to be together when we do commentary
Jeremy didn't create it would hold your
hand during it yes but we will be in the
same room together next time god damn it
thanks everybody for hanging out don't
forget to support scum and villainy
Cantina they put on this wonderful
stream for you man
you know JC asked us we weren't gonna do
this we wanted to spend Star Wars day
with our families like everybody else
but JC called us and and we come
a-runnin and stuff like that so deep ah
anyway you can help out the scum and
villainy cantina buy a gift card or come
see it when like we're allowed to open
which I understand maybe soon there it
sounds like governor's talking about
opening and right now I said we're in
stage one stage two is restaurants and
and bars and stuff like that but at low
capacity so that means people might be
able to come back to the scum and
villainy Cantina fairly soon and stuff
and if you do love to get back cover
yourself in a human prophylactic with a
minor yes
if you're bored kids and you got money
to spend head over that Kevin Smith
club.com mark where do you want to send
folks I will send you all just to go to
go to go to the [ __ ] foundation let's
let's let's raise a little bit more
money for for the retailers who the
comic book store retailers who are a big
me hit about as hard as their small
business can be hit so it's B IMC
foundation go on the internet just
donate some money just help help an
industry that's struggling to get back
on its feet get back on its feet
absolutely and boy do I feel like a
piece of [ __ ] for being let go to my
website but mark is absolutely right as
always an IMAX movie will do a Mark said
big thanks for hanging out with us here
on fat man be on on Star Wars day I
can't do this show without that guy
who's either to that side or this side
or up wherever they're putting us in
formation
he's Brady Bunch to round me somewhere
his name is Mark Bernard you give it up
for the great mark Bernard music oh
thank you mr. Smith so much fun spinning
the Star Wars day with you may the 4th
that is fat man beyond for this week
although you'll see us on Thursday
there's something we can say hey man
Thursday we're doing fat man beyond live
streaming from the canteen as per usual
so don't forget mark down in your
calendars but for now we hand you back
to the stream there's been fat man
beyond for fat man beyond I'm Kevin
Smith
I'm mark barnard tune in next time same
fat town same fat channel SModcast calm
or youtube.com slash Kevin Smith may the
4th be with you look under forever